[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right all right
testing testing one two one two
about 10 43 a.m eastern
talk to me chad big bad big mad mo
drew what's going on sean sue bad coffee
let me know what's going on man i had a
lot of issues trying to set up right now
and i just want to make sure a ton of
audio issues i want to make sure
i am good i'm clear that y'all hear me
so if y'all in that live chat
please talk to me it is much appreciated
we'll do a couple of sound checks
in a minute i gotta get the law i didn't
even wake the lords up man
it's that type of day so chat if y'all
seeing me talk to me let me know what's
going on right quick
all right all right sending data to
twitch all right that's good twitch i'll
see you
all right so sound good on my bag mode
thank you thank you what's going on
thank you sean zeus appreciate it
christopher hart what's going on we're
almost live yeah we're a little running
behind i'm trying to get things together
um my a lot of issues on my end i think
i was able to resolve it thank you
graphic guard if you're in there if you
hear me because you saved the day
you know what i'm saying we're gonna get
benji in here benji's been waiting
patiently so this is all on me y'all
we're gonna scramble to get everybody up
and the lords and all that good stuff so
i will be back
and then we'll do another mic check to
guess make sure y'all can hear them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right testing testing one two is
cognito here the legendary
benji sales in the room we're gonna do
some chad benji talk to the people real
quick just make sure they can hear you
hello hello everyone hope you can hear
me good
excited for a great chat today exactly
yo chad talk to me man we got the
legendary let me know y'all can hear him
good
okay shonzo says i still good sounds
good that's great but let me know if you
guys hit benji that is the key that was
the issues this morning
so chad talk to me sure sun xbox 448
what's going on bro
all right eagles fans sound good y'all
saying sounds good but i need you to say
specifically
sounds good then i will be at ease
chris hart so might say benji sound good
yeah i need that all right so
all right my man thank you very much
thank you very much so what i'm going to
do is we're going to go
mute because you know the king is going
to come in here and he going about to
give us a copyright strike because he's
going to come in here with some musical
theme song
and we're not gonna do that so we're
gonna mute and we'll see y'all in a few
minutes thanks a lot jonathan b
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right i think we are live
chat let us know what's going on because
it's been a hell of a morning
but anyway and we are live
welcome to the iron lord podcast and the
lords of gaming.net
episode number 169 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's date
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got the recent success
of grounded
halo infinite announcements and ea
creeping on wb to discuss so we could
get right into it
i want to introduce a lloyd who is not
only one of our top analysts in the
games industry
with his passion for sales metrics and
research and industry trends
truly exemplifies his moral duty to
correct misinformation
introducing the independent video games
industry analyst and host of the benji
sales youtube channel
the lord of reset era fc predictions
and the original phantom thief mask on
youtube
live from an undisclosed location
and making his debut into the realm
of the lords mommy lord benji sales how
are we doing sir
i am doing amazing wow
wow what what an intro
i i can tell you that uh that just took
my hype level to the next level
thank you so much for the kind words i'm
really excited to be here today
um thanks so much that was an amazing
intro
you're the roman law you're a lord in
your realm a lord at what you do it's
only right we show you the
proper respect here at the round table
man how you been with any games you've
been playing what's been going on with
you man
yeah yeah i've been good um working my
way through ghost of tsushima still you
know that's the yeah that's pretty good
very blossom so we put the cherry
blossoms continue yeah yeah
we've been playing some goats uh this
year i've been replaying through all of
the halo games with the master chief
collection
yeah i'm getting ready for infinite so i
think right after it goes to tsushima
i'm up to halo 3 so and then caleb
three's next yep
okay awesome getting going through the
halo chronicle okay okay
that's what's up baby definitely good to
have you in the realm man we got a lot
to get into
so you already know we have the four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the realm here at the round table
with our new updated five minute intro
y'all
my girl host with the girls my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of reviews and the how of the young
wolf
my man lord addict how are we doing sir
i'm exhausted but i'm here
salute salute sir thank you for waking
up with the required time
i got you up early what's funny is i
didn't tell my brother that was doing an
early podcast because we only do it
during the football season thank god
that's not happening
oh no that's going to happen we'll talk
about it what are you talking about
okay what happened
so i'm sitting there and i i wake up i'm
like what time is it zachary he's like
oh don't worry you got plenty time
before the podcast
i'm like oh god what's up
it's 10 30 of my call all right no you
got to get off the computer because he's
playing world of warships he's like but
the broadcasters are starting you know
it's like it starts at 11.
special benji time what you've been
playing
everything anything we're playing the
only thing i've really played this whole
week is road company
okay cool yeah i think i've already put
a day in road company
cool yeah people been loving it man yeah
it's it's it's the best multiplayer i've
played in a long time
time that's the new time that we got a
tick time system down benji so because
uh i'll remember
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience
and also the south stradamus mr offline
profile illuminati and lord patreon of
the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
good morning gentlemen
i like 11 a.m voices i love 11 a.m boys
i look like a hobo and i look like i'm
under the table
you know unshaven shaving
so what you been doing the game's been
playing sir yes sir i finally
finally finally got to the second act of
ghost of sushima
so got through all that first part
that game rocked by rock or something
unlike something we tend to explore and
not just do
maine missions no exactly say something
i'm here
[Laughter]
after i beat it i was like that was that
was harder than it should have been
like that was worth it it should have
been what do you think i think
so real quick on it um yeah i'm i'm
tending now more to play more like a
samurai like
the thing is i you know i love stealth
games but i feel like the stealth
i'm not going to say it's undercooked
here but the game is is made for the for
the samurai combat really the stealth is
so i agree i agree yeah it's a it's all
right
but it doesn't feel like a splinter cell
or something like that
it's not that so i tend to lean towards
salmon right now
yeah the it's like i was saying like
yo you're stupid
oh
i finally got it right guys the same
camera it was just
i i it was not cooperating with me and
it finally did so one more super chat's
off
and we got midway monster with the final
super chat not up on purpose
glad to catch the show i hope he should
go prime time
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this
aka the access gamer who
the lord of combat sports king of the
statues
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert
movement oh beloved lord king how are we
doing sir
i'm doing fantastic i've been playing
ghosts
and um i'm still uh in the first act
whatever
i've been playing a little bit of
grounded and i you know neon abyss and
i'm
i'm done but go ahead
i don't like what the zone is doing
lately and there
uh there's been investigations into
their fights
because the zone fights has definitely
been completely watered down there's
been huge mismatches
and it's been weird knockouts that's
been going on and
they're under investigation but the pbc
in showtime is coming back in september
so that's when combat talk will
come back from me um the ufc is trying
their damn disc
but a lot of people keep uh coming up
and popping up with colvin and if one
person on your team
can't just go with the whole card can
actually go to uh crap so
shout out to people fading out
i think all professional sports man like
bass baseball's trying it right now and
baseball's probably doing the worst that
it is the whole team yeah
it's just like they they they didn't
yeah they're hardheaded they did one
they're not controlling what the players
are doing after they leave the stadium
right
and then at the same time they're
playing in too many damn stadiums
there's too much traveling going on if
they were gonna do this they needed to
isolate them
they had to do like the nbas exactly
what sucks about the whole thing is that
uh these dudes they told them no
spitting no dapping none of this stuff
and they could continue
to do the dapping this this that's just
yeah if if you if you're going to be
about if you're going to be part of the
team you're going to have this uh this
conscious
effort going forward please do it and
because everybody doesn't
they they really think this is a joke
until it really hit it really
you know and it's unfortunate that that
it has to hit somebody in the face for
them to understand that this is for real
but it sucks but anyway no sports please
it is
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi the sushi
so yeah man shout out to the last word
we had gaming forte on
some nice destiny i wanted to say
congratulations
on that that was hot when you got into
that bag
okay there's a part in there cognito
goes off on both of them off on both of
them
it's about the ice breaker it's about
the uh the
last word gun i think it's the last word
and the hawkmoon and he goes off on them
and they try to defend their position he
uses their position
against them and then he just leaves it
there that's enough
and they had nothing else to say i think
i watched that at least 10 times
little shout out to my brother extremely
passionate destiny is very
very a purest game with exotics and
certain things coming back
huge debate with those they know how to
push the button and i had enough
they would antagonize me but you were
stressed
hold up the icebreakers coming back no
no um moon's coming back so
but people are saying it's not going to
make its original form yeah
amazing it's amazing how just destiny
related can just completely corrupt us
that xbox showcase man the moment
destiny shows yeah it was the best show
ever for me it was all okay it was all
good
so real quick real quick um yeah so i've
been doing that go sashimi of course
grounded in game pass and messenger in
gay past that's what i've been doing man
so look now that we got into what the
lords have been playing i want to focus
on lord benji his video game system
history
his journey as an independent video
games analyst
and of course what led him to creating
the amazing amazing benji sales youtube
channel so let's start from the
beginning benji
what was some of the first video game
systems you had and what got you into
gaming
yeah so it all started for me as a
little kid
like a lot of people my very first
console was the super nintendo
yeah my uh my uncle bought it for me
wow that was my uh my real introduction
to gaming wow
and uh yeah since then it was just like
a lifelong passion you know all the way
up to ps1
ps2 the original xbox 360 really just
yeah my whole life but it all kicked off
with super nintendo nintendo
all right so let me uh give me at least
he's not one of our guests that makes me
feel
really really young that starts off like
i was playing pong back in the day
at least he started out with with the
console i actually
owned that appreciates the younger
demographics
but enough about that we'll get into the
show yo shout out the [ __ ]
shut your mouth this old gamer talk
right there shout out to the fawns
grounding gamer you already know shout
out to stinger
so all right so again super nintendo and
then like from your progression
onward and i have to ask because we got
a fanboy a little bit
um we're a sega ever in your household
sir
no it's crazy
i know it's crazy i uh i never
owned a sega but my uncle the same one
who bought me the super nintendo he uh
he had a sega genesis okay and i would
be over at his house playing all the
time
okay so i still i still had a lot of
sega in my life
but i just didn't have it at home that's
fine that's fine you had access you were
able
to experience the blast processing don't
let cognito lie to you you said you
never had a sega he
his icon was over kick benji
next generation like what was the the
next generations of systems after like
the 16-bit era did you dabble into the
32-bit era did you
like where did you go from there so i
went straight from super nintendo my
next console was the playstation one
um yeah playstation one um
then after that you know back then it
seemed so common for all of us to to go
to friends houses and play consoles you
know i
when i was growing up i just had the one
i always had to pick one you know
it wasn't i was going to get them all
i'd go to a friend's house to play
nintendo 64 and things like that but i
was the playstation one
then uh after that went to the
playstation 2 and then after that i've
had
once we got past the ps2 gen i had every
console for every generation so
360 ps3 wii um wii u
switch xbox one playstation 4 and next
gen get them all too
you know that's what we gotta have all
the time
tell them about that uh elite gaming
status that you're doing sir that
that you're not locked off in a box
talking this fanboy crap like only one
can survive
yeah i'm not a i'm not the biggest fan
of the whole fanboy war stuff i i really
admire people that are like hardcore
fans for
one system like that doesn't bother me
at all i love it i love seeing the
passion but yeah the
the fanboy wars can get a little intense
oh these people will be over there
people will be out there attacking me in
my comment section
what an addict i have god award i got
guard war right here too dude
history love the diversity in the
consoles very cool
so let's get into um actually the games
industry right so um
like what specifically pushed you to
become an
analyst yeah so it all started
you know really as a hobbyist and it
really kicked off way back in the day on
gametrailers.com wow
remembers that website oh yeah yeah um
it started off there i used to be that
was actually the first
video game forum that i was a member of
i joined gametrailers.com
and i remember it was a random thread
and people were talking about the game
fable they were talking about how much
fable had sold
and it just lit a spark in me i found
like i found it super interesting
because it was one of those things you
know growing up i played games i knew
what my friends played
but i found it fascinating knowing what
other people were playing you know once
you see those sales numbers you're like
oh
okay so so this is how popular a game is
yeah it kind of just set off a pattern
there and then i
you know found vgcharts.com
yeah i went on there and started talking
with sales people
eventually neogaf eventually reset era
and uh really just dedicated i mean i've
been doing this now
in a hobbyist way for probably man
probably a decade
wow and uh and it just started getting
like more and more of
a following more and more people kind of
listening to some of my analysis and i
was like
let's take this to the next level and
that's whenever i decided
to make the twitter to make the youtube
and then from there it's just kind of
blown up it's been kind of crazy how
much the twitter's grown so it's
humbling yeah it's humbling absolutely
yo that is pretty awesome let's get this
super chat real quick
shout out to the basement radio arcade
bra whoa
salute lords king i am coming over for
leftovers
god is awesome yes
it is salute to brat basement radio
audience
that this saturday that watch an hour
you ain't been on since this time thing
showed up i'm going to time you all the
time if you come back on again
anyway so cool you know the thing i want
to also talk about um obviously as you
as an analyst um
market trends and and and misinformation
you know so it's like what do you think
i always want to ask you this like what
do you think
most gamers get wrong in terms of
analyzing trends in like npd i think
everything
[Laughter]
there is a lot of that yes there is a
lot of that um i think the thing that
that most people get the most wrong
is that so many people are kind of in
their own bubble
so whatever bubble that is whether it's
the nintendo bubble whether it's a
certain
franchise bubble whatever you kind of
get
locked into this one viewpoint and you
only really look at that you don't look
at how other things are sailing are
selling and i see
all the time misinformation one that
used to drive me crazy
the story has changed now but for a long
time there was this this
like kind of belief going around like
rainbow six siege was a flop
and it was driving me crazy because i
knew how big their player counts were
and uh it had just become this narrative
now it's changed now right so many
people know that game has
tens and tens and tens but initially
with no single player
it it was yeah didn't receive well at
first no no yeah
yeah it started slow and then it really
ramped up but it took a while for
everyone else to kind of catch up to
knowing how much it ramped
it was that weekend that it was um a
free weekend and then it just blew up
after that yeah
yeah and and sometimes these these
stories
about sales and performance they take a
while to
get like known you know what i mean so
many people will be focused on oh hey
this nintendo game that i love sold well
but they don't know anything about how
another game sells
so they just call it a flop i see it all
the time even in my mentions
they'll just be like oh that game's so
terrible and you're like well
actually
[Music]
yeah i would say i would say that's the
thing that people get the most wrong
they just get kind of locked into their
own bubble and don't see the whole
picture
okay fair enough let me get my man shout
out the rising grind with the fallout
attic that's a boy right there make sure
you say something next yeah
rising grind salute man i haven't seen
you early long time brother
it's something too quick real quick
right here
he he was probably laying back in this
chair man i ain't typing nothing right
now you're just gonna take this five
dollars and you're gonna be happy
okay that's what's up man and then like
i said
you get you're seeing this
misinformation now would you say like
that was another factor as far as
leading you
into kind of content creation doing your
own youtube and that kind of stuff
like what was that inspiration to get
into youtube
so the the thing that really pushed me
over the edge onto
youtube and twitter like talking about
it in a big way was actually funnily
enough i
originally thought i watched a lot of
you know kind of funny easy allies
podcasts like this big fan and uh all
the time they would say sales info wrong
i love those channels so i'm not
i mean all the time it was popping up so
i originally thought hey i'm just going
to make a twitter
you know to kind of help these guys out
a little bit maybe just kind of let them
know occasionally as a nice comment i
didn't mean
oh hey just here's some info on it
because it does it gets spread
all over the place so uh that was
definitely part of it the whole
misinformation thing and i know very few
people are doing it
purposefully you know what i mean most
things it takes a lot of time to
research and
yeah that kind of started it off but
then i was like i'm just gonna do my own
thing and then maybe people will pull
from it and luckily they have
okay that's what's up man yeah
definitely like i said during your
history and seeing how one thing i
respect
is how cool you are about presenting the
information you're not you know doing
any type of dish like you said you don't
do it in a disrespectful fashion or
trying to show anybody up but just say
hey this is
actually how things are trending this is
what's going on you know
that kind of thing and it's extremely
informative man so
thank you thank you you do a really
fantastic job with that
so um i'll actually open it up on for q
a and stuff
one thing we got to talk about obviously
is um you know the sales that's going on
in the industry we're seeing a lot of
movement a lot of traffic and stuff like
that
i don't want to talk about i want to
save my question for you a reference to
the ground and stuff because we have a
separate topic for that but another
thing in reference to like for example
um me and you obviously a big ghost fan
goes to shema fan
um just you know the amazing story
cinematography all that stuff
so like i want to talk about like how
that
is viewed as from an ip standpoint as a
new ip like
what are we seeing from a projection
standpoint like
about because we know like it's physical
sold out right like physicals is very
hard to get
so like what are your projections i mean
to say like for go as a new ip for
sucker punch
yeah so ghost of tsushima or sushima has
been a uh
an absolutely phenomenal success it's
actually kind of crazy in fact i think
it over delivered
on what sony were expecting me
personally not so much anyone that
follows my youtube channel i was
predicting over 2 million units for
launch it hit 2.4 million so right in
the range i was expecting
but i think sony actually under
projected
physical copies because it's it's in
japan it's hard to find in the us
it's hard to find physical shortages all
over the place
and usually that happens because game's
doing better than you thought it was
right so uh it started phenomenal legs
are looking encouraging
uh i think it's going to sell over 10
million units wow
yeah i really do that open world genre
has like really
good legs if you look at like horizon
zero dawn for example the
the previous best-selling new ip for
playstation
that went on to sell over 10 million
units and it started slower
than goes to tsushima so it'd be pretty
surprising for it to miss 10 million
um so yeah by far it's going to be the
best selling game sucker punch has ever
made not even
not even close i think that you know at
the end of the day
you could spend millions of dollars on
marketing budgets but the thing that's
going to sell your game the most is
word of mouth yes and that's definitely
what's so ghosts man because i
i didn't expect what i got from ghosts
but i played the ghost like an hour or
two into i was like
yo this is quality like this is good
absolutely
the word of mouth actually seems better
than the reviews you know it got
good reviews like it's like it got bad
reviews it's like a mid-80s meta
but like when you read online at least
like the uh the overall feedback seems
overwhelmingly positive so yeah word of
mouth seems
really good on that game absolutely the
the
the game had such an impression on me i
started going and reading all the bad
reviews like the mid-range reviews
i'm like why is this game getting this
like
no it's true word of mouth really really
spread this thing and it's good to see
sucker punch really get that type of
success
it's really cool so i'm actually going
to open it up y'all to the rest of the
lawyers too because i got i can
talk to video i got tons of questions
but i want to be fair
king is your time i want to open it up
for you guys so specific i know you said
you got some stuff too
any questions you got for this well i
want to do do you want me to roll this
into the the actual halo topic or you
want me to keep this
i want to save anything halo and
grounded i want y'all to save that
because
so that was that was specifically my big
thing because
it's interesting uh just to see where
where microsoft is going
towards trending towards anyway so um so
let me think of another question guy
i got tons i'll just be a fan i got i
got one yes yes
uh benji uh from from looking at
you know the trending and and exactly
where game passes went uh
do you see how how big do you think game
pass can potentially get
massive it's really the future of
microsoft's platform it really is
you know you can even see that clearly
in the xbox showcase they just had
don't get me wrong they were talking
about series x they were mentioning
these things
but clearly you know
yeah game pass was everywhere phil
spencer comes out right off the bat
basically very very early in the show
and is talking about how you're going to
be able to play
all of this yeah i thought that
also skewed uh the games that would be
shown
because a lot of games could have been
shown but if they weren't you know
going to being game pass and i think the
theme of that whole thing was game pass
so it kind of you know it will also
it will make people disappointed in what
they actually got
some people but then it also makes other
people elated but
at the same time this is what they're
trying to push forward
while they get rid of uh xbox live so
getting rid of xbox live and rolling
people into game pass
and and and putting them in an ecosystem
because there's going to be a point
in september when you go to login
and you say oh a game pass and then
you're going to click it and then you're
going to like oh
okay and then when your subscription
runs out do you keep it or do you drop
it
and i think uh the majority of the
people will either keep it
uh opposed to drop it but benji i had a
question for you right
and the question is uh now that we see
that you know um
xbox is doing the you know the game pass
stuff uh
playstation now is going to do a two-day
like basic i saw it like a trial run
type of thing
and playstation is going to be free like
the playstation
live network is going to be free for the
two days and everybody can get on they
can play
you know play with each other as far as
uh you know uh multiplayer games and
stuff like that without that
you mean the stuff that microsoft did in
the 360 area
yeah but i think this is huge because it
shows that jim ryan is willing
to um and that's his name right now no
no i wasn't going to say his whole name
but i'm not doing it because benji's
here
he's being respectful no no yeah totally
respecting the dad she was away today
right yeah and pretty sure that he knows
how what i call them
anyway um but uh
i see that that is like dipping your toe
in the water do you see it the same way
do what do you expect uh those numbers
to do because i think they're trying to
get some type of metrics
to see how many people are willing to
jump in and play multiplayer if it was
free
um yeah so this experimentation that
we're looking at
looks like microsoft might be completely
getting rid of the multiplayer paywall
right now we have playstation like you
said kind of experimenting with this
it's gonna be very
interesting to see how it all plays out
here here's what i'll say
i feel like microsoft is a lot more
better in position to drop the paywall
than sony
for multiplayer specifically because
game pass is already such a success
game pass is already well over 10
million subscribers playstation now for
example
if sony tries to position ps now
eventually
as the replacement for ps plus like how
we kind of think microsoft's doing
they're gonna have to get that
subscriber number way higher they're
under
i believe if i'm remembering correctly
uh you know off the top my head i
believe they're under 2 million subs on
ps now
still um it could be around there now
you know we haven't gotten an update in
a while so it could be in the two
million range
um but it's significantly behind game
pads i'm actually so
didn't it start first though it did yeah
one thing that they've
been doing that i'm surprised people
ain't noticed is that yeah you know how
like
xbox live gold has a 50 off if you buy
it in a year quantity yeah
um sony's doing that with with the the
playstation now thing if you buy
if you buy the whole year up front you
only have to pay sixty dollars oh wow
okay
i'm sorry good you continue i was just
gonna say i
could see a scenario eventually where
just all multiplayer goes
free across the board you know it's
already that way on pc
so you know there's already a giant
you know base that doesn't have to pay
for online i could see that happening
eventually but you're gonna have to try
and get that money somewhere else
because
yeah yeah playstation plus and xbox live
make billions of dollars for these
companies so
it's all about where can you funnel that
instead
xbox clearly thinks that's game pass
they think that they're going to be able
to get that much higher
they're well over 10 million the fact
this is on pc as well is huge i i think
you're going to see game pass up into
the 20s 30s millions of subscribers
not that long i think into next gen
you're going to see it
so microsoft i feel like better in
position to drop that pay wall
sony might feel the heat they might feel
the pressure especially if microsoft
really is going to announce this soon
that might put some pressure on them
right um it's going to be interesting
that's going to be going in the next gen
let me uh let me add one to that because
it initially came
out too that oh i think they were
speaking to aaron greenberg in some form
of an interview
and you know people are saying well is
it profitable right now
and you know his response was kind of
like hey don't worry about us we'll be
fine
so the vibe is right now again i don't
have any hard data
i'm just going over speculation what i'm
hearing is that they are not
necessarily profitable with game pass
exactly at this moment more of an
investment stage
and that they're looking at the long
game do you see
that is how they're playing it right now
like what what is your data showing as
far as
game pass and their whole you know drive
to
i guess integrate this fully yeah so
everything i can look at you know
the the hard hardcore detailed
game pass stuff's all super nda so
unfortunately
but just looking at uh just looking at
microsoft's financial reports
just looking at the things they say
publicly what i'd say is clearly it is
already having
an effect on their revenue streams
they've talked about in their quarterly
earnings reports now for multiple
quarters in a row
they've specifically mentioned
subscription growth as part of their
revenue to help offset hardware declines
right
so clearly it is boosting their revenue
the question in regards to profit
probably not super profitable for them
yet i i'd be surprised if they're taking
a big
loss on it i they might but it's
probably more just kind of like around
break even not a big money maker for
them yet but not a
not like something that's really
siphoning off a lot of money or else i
think their
i think their actual financials would
look a lot worse if it was really
hurting them
um it's probably just more sitting
around that break-even point
um but yeah it's a long term play people
got to remember netflix for example
infamously took gigantic losses for a
very long time
for investing in creating original
content
and getting in for a cheaper price you
know everyone always jokes about the one
dollar trials and stuff for
game pass but this is all subscriptions
almost they almost all have some sort of
trial cheap entry point because a lot of
the the research shows
if you can get someone in the door and
subscriber
it's pretty rare they unsubscribe right
as long as they like the services i mean
obviously if you have a really bad
service
stay here stay there easy
as long as you're offering a quality
product
your retention if you get someone in
cheap is typically very high
so maybe someone's paying a buck right
now but the statistical odds are
a huge chunk of those people are going
to stay on and be spending more than a
dollar
eventually so yeah it's just a long term
play a lot of people need to remember
game pass is not that old
it's already over 10 million subs i mean
just imagine
i mean like i said i expect to see 20
and 30 million subscriber numbers in
just a few years
yeah it's pretty that's pretty
impressive that's pretty impressive i
think what people don't realize too
at the end of the day is like you know
microsoft ankles say they make money
till they get the investment they put
into game pass too
so yes and i think that you know they
consider buying the studios all that
that that was an investment towards game
pass right yeah because
they want that content to go into it and
they probably spent
billions of dollars in the past three or
four years to get to this moment
well i felt netflix turn around point
was when they started making original
content their own stuff
yes and and their original content
is some of the most compelling content
because they're going up against you
know showtime and hbo and i really
believe they knock showtime and hbo out
the box be honest with you
i haven't subscribed to showtime nor hbo
in such a long time
only when game of thrones or something
like
you know you tend to gravitate back
towards the the big two
but netflix and hulu have been holding
down this mid-tier spot
for so long with original content and i
believe microsoft is trying to
get to that space and i know sony can
definitely get to that spaces
are they willing to do date and date
with their
um you know with games like go to
shashima
potentially like benji said can sell 10
million
that is a deterrent when it comes to
releasing it inside a playstation now
right
you know because then you you lose or
you
intentionally lose that 10 million but i
also think it's a double-edged sword
because
you open yourself up to so many more
people
right it doesn't preclude you from
purchasing the game once it's inside a
service
and you know that's just my my level of
frustration with it
uh do you see any metrics that indicates
that sony
is leaning towards that because they're
doing pc stuff now
do you see them like we've seen yeah
right we've seen the success that king
is saying
when they've dabbled so to speak right
they haven't gone as full
as microsoft in that space but we've
seen death stranding
we've seen that there are there are
rumors i have to speculate this is
speculation
you know that other things may come you
know
what what do you think about that do you
think it's a situation where
you know obviously we're seeing the
success of microsoft recently that they
may say hey
you know we want to dabble in that or
you think that they're so tied
to the console space and selling
consoles as opposed to microsoft's
philosophy with most more of getting you
into the ecosystem
yeah yeah i think sony is in a bit of a
weird spot
um they are still really attached to
that
console like really really attached to
it and
they're still also really really
attached to um full price game sales
and there's a specific reason for that
it's because they still sell
so many consoles and so many games you
know both the the ps4 and the games
themselves are just i mean
it's crazy the performance they've had
this generation but
here's what i think i think sony is
going to
not go as all in as microsoft where it's
day and date
right off the bat it's on game pass it's
on pc eventually it's on xcloud it's
just going to be
everywhere microsoft wants their games
to be as easy
to get a hold of as possible they're
trying to remove that barrier of entry
i think sony's not going to go that far
but i do think you're going to see
quicker turnarounds i won't be surprised
if you see like
hey one year after launch these games
are in p.s now
so i've been trying to tell people
continue yeah that would that would not
surprise me because they do got to get
those ps now subscribers up somehow
they've got to do it somehow you are
going to still just see a natural slow
increase as they get more third-party
stuff but
the real reason game pass is as big as
it is is because people know
when halo drops day one i'm going to be
able to get it in game pass when
pixel drops day one i'm gonna get fable
and game pass like that's
really what drives it the third party
stuff's great too but it's knowing that
that first party stuff's there
i'd be surprised if sony goes day one
because they make
so much money off of full box game sales
but
i do think you'll see quicker
turnarounds i think because right now
sometimes games take like two or three
years to get into ps now
i could see a situation where it's like
12 months after launch
right ps now for god of war two or you
know not two yeah
yeah or whatever i can understand that
so so i got a question for you okay
obviously we see that sony's going
a little bit more pc friendly
we saw we've seen horizon zero dawn you
know it's coming to pc
do you think there's a world where
horizon sells so well
that we'll see playstation games come to
pc like a year
mon a year after launch it's possible
horizon's definitely a trial run
i i i'm very confident that's exactly
what's going on with horizon
yeah i feel like within oh sorry you
finished oh i was just going to say it
it seems
very clear to me this is sony testing
the waters for two things a how much
it's going to sell
and b what sort of pr impact it has
because sony is very i would say
somewhat clued into their audience and
that they very
much pay attention to what's being
discussed online like big time
they they're very clued into that so i
think it's partially looking at pr will
people care
will people freak out but the end-all
be-all is how well does this sell
i expect horizon to sell multiple
million units on steam
multiple millions um yeah it's they're
going to have more games on steam
there's just no doubt in my mind
or and maybe actually maybe epic game
stories
i was just getting ready to ask you that
i was just gonna
jumping right into it i'm just gonna
actually being that they made that
initial
uh baseline investment in uh epic
you know themselves uh do you feel that
that's going to skew
their uh pc releases towards the epic
store first for limited time
uh or would it just you know be released
in steam and epic at the same time well
both
i like i i guess i want to double all
this question too that's a great
question okay
like because of that relationship you
know will it
will they just go epic exclusively or i
mean horizontally obviously was before
the deal but
i'm just curious about that relationship
that's a good question all right
if i had to guess and this is a guess i
would think they'll
probably just support both because even
though
sony did invest into epic games and it
sounds like a big number in terms of
percent you're talking
about yeah it's about one percent yeah
so it is an investment it is hundreds of
millions of dollars but
in terms of percent it's not huge so i
definitely think
moving forward let's say theoretically
god of war does come out on pc
right i would definitely expect an epic
game store release it would be very
strange to invest in the company and not
gonna put it on it yeah but
yeah but let me stop you for a second
because i would i would guess it'd be on
steam too
all right good good point i guess my
quest the reason why i'm so curious
about it is because
based on epic's entry into the pc gaming
space it's been extremely aggressive
right
it's been we're locking exclusives in
here and the steam community was not
happy with epic's very aggressive play
with exclusives in
so i guess i am curious if if now that
they have this relationship with sony
may would it be a situation where they
say okay
we're gonna do both eventually sony
right but maybe they locked them into a
three-month six-month type of exclusive
deal on the epic store first before it
goes to steam do you do you see a
situation maybe like that with epic
i don't know if they can demand that
based on the relationship but do you
understand what i'm kind of going
getting at with this
yeah i definitely see where you're going
it is
possible it is definitely possible
sony's such a powerful company too
though it's it's uh
you know they can kind of make their own
demand too on that relationship
i uh i think horizon's gonna sell too
strong for sony to ignore it i mean i
really think people are going to be
shocked how much that game sells on pc
it's been in the top it's been in the
top 10 right
yeah i mean since it went up for
pre-order it's essentially been top 10
the whole time this is a game that's
gonna
i mean do crazy on steam so it could
happen
it very well could especially like you
said if it was like a three or six month
window
i'd be surprised if you saw like a one
or two year exclusivity
um but it's it's entirely possible
definitely clearly
expect some uh very close ties between
epic and sony moving forward it's not a
coincidence that uh unreal engine five
was demoed on the playstation five for
example
right yeah close relationship mm-hmm
sorry to solve it and get the super
chats to solve for your questions let's
all right circle that's first we have
the grounded gamer with the final two
chat can we just talk about those load
times and go fast wow
don't if you haven't got an ssd in there
yeah
you know it feels like they know exactly
what they're doing
yeah but no time
yeah and then we have midway monster
with the five dollars
yeah does benji or the panel believe
that they will do game pass for a year
at 60
like live as a replacement no 16 no
i doubt i mean there's just too much
that goes into gameplay it's 129
right and then when you start to break
down maybe
if you buy it all in one uh shot it is
like a month or two off
um i think that's the best that anybody
can do for you
uh because soon the content is going to
be too compelling for you to even deny
it
so when you start to think about next
generation games being
uh possibly 70 if you take two
games you literally have game pass so
you have to figure it out you have to
make a ying and a yang decision now
uh is it going to be the two games that
i'm gonna get or am i gonna get a year
of game pass with
uh potentially uh 300 different type of
games that i can play in it
and so you're going to have to start
making hard decisions with your wallet
brother
i think i think the i don't i don't want
to say it's entirely not possible
the the variable is what sony does if
sony starts making
ps now compelling and you know they
start to put stuff in there
faster and then we don't know how much
pressure like right now i've always said
game pass
isn't like the post date like i don't
think they've 100
went behind game pass they put money
behind it they built a structure behind
it but i think
they're in game with game passes next
generation that's when they're really
gonna absolutely they've been ramping up
to get to this yeah and
i feel like once once next gen starts
and they start amping up the the
output they're doing what they're
putting in game fast uh
especially for the for the price because
i mean you can go out and buy a lock car
i know people or some people don't think
that exists
and then you can get a a subscribe to
game pass
you can literally leave there for three
to four hundred dollars like leave the
store yeah get taken my question be
quiet
have access to all these games and it's
just like if that starts happening and
sony starts losing ground
because of game pass they're gonna have
to respond right yeah and then
if they respond strong enough
microsoft's gonna have to respond so
they'll solve i wanna get dizzy and i'm
gonna let you go cause you've been
waiting on your question
um shout out to disneylandgamer.net
c-o-o
i need everyone to acknowledge the x-men
shirt that benji is wearing
the superior comet crew for the fans be
going avengers
salute where's kai batu damn disney
stuff
he calls him like the 90210 of marvel
it's funny
so he sees benji with that shirt so this
is like yes
one of my x-men brothers i already know
what they feel like crazy
so get your questions off sir so benji
this month
obviously we're expecting we're
expecting console prices
to be announced pre-orders and we're
expecting the potential announcement of
the lockhart
so we've also always we speculated about
what the lockhart would do to
to the market once it's announced what
do you
in actuality what do you think
announcing a lot card that launches
day and date with the series x does to
the market in terms of
series x sales in terms of the xbox
platform in general and how it affects
playstation sales and i want to add
something on to that that i see a lot of
people say
benji do you think there is a market for
the lockhart continue
yes actually so lockhart has been
something i have been
so back and forth on myself i've been
one month i'm like hey lockhart seems
like a genius idea
the next month i'm like man
i'm like i've been all over the place
with it i actually think maybe
internally at microsoft they've been a
little
unsure as well considering we still
haven't even seen this console
there's been not even a single hint or
wording from microsoft about it i do
think it's going to release
i do think so um but you know i think
it's
partially a marketing challenge
you know especially for microsoft
because this box is
rumored to be weaker you know than the
playstation 5 much weaker than the
series
x still going to have some big jumps
over current gen with like the
ssd the cpu things like this so i think
they've been just kind of taking their
time figuring out how are we going to
market this how are we going to
you know make sure it does well but also
not take away from series
x i just think there's probably a lot
that's gone into it
in regards to market performance i think
it's gonna do
well especially if yeah especially if
they're targeting
lower resolutions here's my thing as
long as it
it it can run games great as long as the
games
besides resolution are going to be
primarily very similar
tons of people have 4k tvs now but it's
still a fact that ton of people
don't and especially whenever you have
yeah especially when you have people
with kids you know that that their kids
are younger they just play minecraft
right they just play
lego don't buy him a 4k yeah
you hear that your tcl dude
especially you know i i see that with a
lot of the fathers in our community
they're like
i'm getting a series x but i'm getting
him uh he gave him the little joint yeah
it's not yeah the children i'm going to
purchase at least
uh two to three lock cards for myself
with multiple televisions it makes no
sense for me
if my primary gaming space is already
set up for
a 4k 120 hertz uh situation
i don't really game in those other um
areas
like that so 1440p 60 frames per second
that's fantastic for me
and i can do that and i can save a whole
bunch of money in doing so i don't need
to keep up with the joneses if i got it
one place
i can go to that one place and i'd like
to stay in one place and play games
there
so back then i'm saying i'm sorry okay
no no like me personally like i feel
like a vlog car
when they do announce it i think that's
they're going to market the lockhart
more than they mark the series x and
that's just me
interesting i think pr from a price
point they know that's going to be more
appealing than you know the 4k
resolution so i i think they're going to
they're definitely going to market the
series x
right but when it comes to stuff like
the super bowl uh you know if walking
dead still a thing
in a couple years like those are going
to be the place where they show
the lockhart because people are going to
see that 300 400
price tag and they're going to grip
towards more that than anything
yeah i guess but i got to get market
them hand in hand
i don't think they market them no man i
mean
to benji's point in saul's point you
know marketing up until this point has
been the most powerful the most is the
most that
non-stop non-stop right and it's just
like there's been i mean
we are the hardcore we know this thing
exists
but to the masses you know the casual he
only and i think that's
where the lockhart comes in honest i
honestly think
all right shout out to phil dominus
maximum spencer
um i think that's the genius
in this this is this is the backhand
all right um it's it's telling you that
we are the most powerful
if you want to do uh 4k 120 frames per
second
you're doing it over here and they've
been really pushing us 120 frames per
second stuff they've been really
out there with it telling you what the
frames per second you know and 60 frames
forcing sony to
say games are going to be 60 okay calm
down people
um and no i like that but at the same
time
they know in the beginning of this
generation
resolution gate was huge right um so
you take away the power talk right
so you know sonny's talking speed and
they're like yo calm down we got a fast
ssd as well
we know we do ssd stuff too velocity
architecture
yeah so just check us out when we you
know head the head with them with their
without third parties
right all right but price was where sony
came
in and i don't think you talk price
until they drop
price and then they can switch the
narrative on it's like a pivot
right when you can undercut your
competition
and deliver same close the same
performance because you can use the same
wordage that they use down
dynamic 4k playstation pros using
dynamic 4k
xbox one x was using a 4k right
dynamic 4k with this with the lockhart
i think that's the genius in
undercutting and
this is where you know a benji and sal's
point comes in
that is that system sells more and where
uh
addict's point come in it sells more or
is marketed more
than the series that we already market
the series x you already know it's the
most powerful right and to stay at this
point in the gym
not the country i'm sorry um to stick at
the point of chat you you are right in
the sense that series x price still
hasn't been revealed yet too
right that's the aspect yeah well i
think it's it's like i said you know at
the end of the day
they know price is above everything it's
above any type of thing that you want to
sell if you have the cheapest
and still an effective product you're
going to do
great and i think that is the reason
shout out to the switch
i think at the beginning you know
obviously you know the um
the the the series x and the lockhart
were in research and development years
before this came out right
i think if microsoft could go back they
would probably stop the lockhart for
coming out because i don't think they
knew that they could be so close to sony
price rise
and i do think they're going to be close
and i think that log car
is supposed to be that thing that comes
out and that's what's marketed
and i think series x will be marketed
but they want to focus on we got the
cheapest
because any slogan doesn't matter if you
got the cheapest we've seen that at the
beginning of
this generation that they were 100
cheaper and it don't matter
what the you know there was definitely a
power narrative right but what's the
easiest bet
yo this thing's more strong yo this is a
hundred dollars cheaper
like jonathan b's giving us time he's
hilarious
oh yeah we gotta get this look look man
you can't time us we time each other
we got luke lower the incipit ghost for
two dollars super chat
i spent money on this instead of
upgrading my tcl
instead of getting this tcl string
[Music]
good i got you you know what i'm saying
so he's stepping his game up so look at
the ghost
i could i could just statement with his
glasses hey cognitive what is this tco
that's the homie that's the holy sound i
like ghosts ghost is actually one of my
favorite
that's my guy
what i love is when people look at the
tv and they hear my voice
you got people looking at tcl's
difference
they walk in the store and they don't
look that way no more
you guys got to do what i do it comes in
one ear out the other i got a tcl right
here on this
frauding you right now because i'm gonna
have to hit him with this because he
already
alert you know why i'm hitting him with
this because his tcl is already gone
he's sitting there fraud and acting like
he's gonna be there for like me
for life tcl no it's not we ain't
talking about how the the least of it
being on my walk
yeah moving and looking we didn't get
respect
to add on to this last because it's a
great topic as far as pricing
strategy lockhart you know the thing
that i pick people i feel
and i shout out to brad pitt's
conversation with him you know that
people
i thought was the the most underrated
announcement at sony's conference
was the announcement of the digital
edition
playstation 5. so my question is
you know do you see a scenario where
they try to position this thing
to combat lockhart and we know discs
don't cost
that much but would they be willing to
take you think a real financial hit to
get into a sweet spot to try to
compete with lockhart on the lower end
skew
yeah um i absolutely think sony's taking
a loss on the digital console
i'll be shocked if they don't to be
honest with you i think that is the
primary reason that console exists
because this this is just a guess we
don't have final pricing yet but i'm
expecting playstation 5 to be 500
and i'm expecting series x to come in at
4.99 as well
um and i i suspect sony plans on taking
a
loss on the all digital and people will
say
i mean i think that i think that the old
digital's gonna be 3.99
i just do yeah i really do i really do
think it's gonna be 400
and people will say hey you know a disk
drive doesn't cost 100 bucks it
absolutely does not
but when someone buys that all digital
console
you're ensuring for the lifetime of that
generation they're not buying a single
disk because they cannot put it in their
console
and digital margins are so much higher
than physical this so much
you you don't take a retailer hit you
don't take a production
hit um for making the games for making
the cases so you're gonna
every single game you sell you're making
more profit off of it
than if you sold a physical copy so so
maybe that disk drive doesn't cost 100
bucks but over the lifetime of that
consumer you're getting a lot more than
a hundred dollars back from them yeah
so so this is this is my thinking if i
was at sony they have people waist
smarter than me there but
if i was at sony i would be 100
positioning the all digital to take a
loss
um to get that entry price point and
cheaper you never know they could do
something crazy and price it at the same
but with a larger
ssd but i yeah i think that would be a
mistake i think the original needs to be
cheaper and quite a bit cheaper
personally just just like you said
even if they go in and they purchase two
to three games those two degree three
games are
actually uh at a greater value than if
you brought the disc
system and brought the same two to three
games because
like he said no packaging no
distribution nothing
this game got a hundred percent to you
without even having to reach
the retail and split the money off so
yeah they can definitely take a hundred
dollar loss on it and it only cost 20
18 1875 to put that disk drive inside
yeah and plus one of the things that you
know you really have to look at like
we're talking that from a first party
aspect
you know when you lock down the disk and
not let them go to gamestop
yet you're getting that 30 from every
third party not in gamestop gamestop has
been completely cut out of this
and imagine like someone picks up a
digital and they buy two
two to three games at launch you've made
that money back just right there
instantly yep i agree 100 i think it's
going to be sold as at a loss and i
think the regular playstation 5 might be
a
slight profit because the rumor is rumor
is manufacturing on it's around 450
bucks
give or take so if you're selling the
digital at a little bit of a loss but
then you sell the
standard at a little bit of a profit
they're going to probably balance each
other out
yeah exactly it's a wash and then you're
making more money off of the digital
game
so i'd be shocked i think it'd be a
really bad move
if the all digital is not a lot cheaper
than the disc i think
you'll get better benji let me ask you a
question
i know this is this is kind of slimy you
don't even have to answer it
do you think that sony purposely has
a lot more diskless ones available
then then they do have the one with the
dislike we do
we don't have any disc ones right now
but we do have like
a lot of timeless ones it's like for
every three they make up a disc they're
six that's
skewing manufacturing
do you think that's a possibility yeah
yeah
remember the playstation 3 right when
they had they had the 20 gig model and
then they had the 60
mile george very hard to find the 60 gig
model like the 20 was all over the place
interesting man that camera making us
look bad so
what do you think of this question sir
uh
to be honest it would not shock me at
all
let's let's use history as an example
right because history a lot of times can
tell us the future
and let's look at what microsoft just
did this past holiday
what was the easiest xbox to find i can
tell you right now
it was the xbox one s all digital
that was the cheapest price console this
holiday it was
the main hardware that they were
shipping to stores i can tell you that
from my connections with retail world
um it was it was a ton of those flooding
into stores it was not a coincidence it
was not an accident
um so i don't know i don't know sony's
manufacturing i don't know if they're
planning on 50 50 60 40 whatever but all
i could
say is that uh it would not shock me at
all if they had the digital youth year
to access because here's the thing
microsoft and sony both are trying to
marginalize game stop out of the market
yeah and the use and the used game
market they really are
they're they're they're doing it more
consumer friendly now than what
microsoft originally envisioned
microsoft originally tried to shut that
down
but they're doing it more pro consumer
now but
make no mistake they want digital
digital
wanted we got the hour bar we're gonna
get the time thing so soft get the um
super chats and then we'll move on
cause we have uh okay the wise old gamer
with the five dollar superchat i think
that that the lockhart discussion was
held due to price
why announce the weaker sku if you're
not going to follow it up with its price
makes sense makes sense makes sense what
else we got so and then we have
wandering dutch hold on dutch salute
it jump me crazy wandering dutch with
the five pounds super chat afternoon
gents
fire podcast as always
we're gonna get you on there brother
good interview i believe you had this
song of iron
devs on your show good interview check
out the dutch
good guy what else we got then we have
mariano pompa with the five dollar super
chat
salute lords where do you guys see the
cost for the memory cards going for
next-gen
is going to cost like 200 dollars memory
card like ps1
they're about that size they're about
their size
yeah those things is going to cost you
like 200 you want memories
you're gonna pay they're
you know i'm an xbox dude and i thought
that was completely shady
right i mean i'm gonna say you when you
went proprietary when we hear that word
proprietary
people already done
understand your wallet is going to be
proprietary as well
i know what was going down sony is
purposely
being ambiguous when it comes to this
whole thing
they're not telling they tell you hey
you listen uh you can swap your your um
ssd out but with a variety of partners
that have to have that exact tech spec
nothing currently on the market is
supporting this but
at a later date we'll let you know
what's available
and when you see the joints and it costs
the same price as your console
yeah i mean probably best off trying to
find a nice 10 terabyte
usb 3.0 and then you store everything
there
and then when you want to play it you
you move it over to the internal drive
and you can use all those top features
and then take it over good bro
okay whatever get that get the super
chat we got to move on
there we go smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat lord addict you don't
want that halo war smoke with luke the
ghost
the monster on that joint
i'm rolling with attic he i'm wrong
i think i think i i think well if he's a
master i'm a grand master
oh i thought you said ghost is yeah we
haven't seen addicts
we haven't seen attic's final form yet
look at you quote
chat what is the point of this game of
chicken on price
what's the point i mean it's it's the
stock it's the strategy
what the hell is wrong with you what am
i playing check this out
i'll answer for benji real quick uh he
told me if i'm wrong i think
because 500 is probably the spot
that it's most likely going to be and
i'll maybe both don't want to be the
first necessarily
to say it i mean that's that's my guess
just real quickly benji what do you
think in reference to that
i agree i think a the price is going to
be pretty high so that's going to be a
scary thing to come out with and then i
also think
b i think xbox 100
100 plans on significantly undercutting
sony on lockhart don't be surprised if
lockhart's three hundred dollars
wow oh you already had first exclusive
i thought it was gonna be 2.99 as well
time the number the number that i was
carrying was
249 to 279. oh
that's spicy that's spicy sauce we
caught up uh we have schmidty smith with
the 10
super chat we here at smitty smith
enterprises are partnering with lord
king
discard actively to start actively
removing
all tcls from people's homes
thank you shout out to the tcl removal
program i just want to take one second
to say that you all have an amazing
community
these super chats i'm loving them
they're hilarious
you guys
does tcl make memory cards asking for
myself
i had to mute myself and turn off the
camera because i want it
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
cut that that little clip out
that's going on twitter he's making
clips
[Music]
time time we don't need to talk about
that time i already got what i wanted
that's it we're good all right cool all
right so now we caught up get on to the
joint
last thing and this is something that we
always ask all
the guests lord benji we got to ask you
i need
your top five video games or franchises
of all
time no pressure no pressure oh my
goodness no pressure
ooh that is tough that is tough okay
we're going all the time all generations
no specific order just you know okay i'm
gonna put the halo franchise up there
for me
that that as a franchise that franchise
just means a lot to me
some of my best memories ever were halo
2
system link parties with my friends all
piling into a house playing
playing halo 2 multiplayer all night
yeah
yeah yeah that's some of my best gaming
memories ever so i got to put the halo
franchise in there
um i forgot what else we got one more
i'm gonna put uh and this is funny
because we just got a uh super chat
not like it but i'm gonna put red dead
redemption too
thank you might not invite you back
though
it's fine i already got my super chat
man
i still have no reason to be attacked
there are you scared of insipid ghosts
you're coming after me
wow is that what it is red dead
[Music]
uh dorian acting just blew my mind um
i'm gonna put uh i'm gonna go to japan
here i'm gonna put the final fantasy
franchise in there
which one which one which one
i got i gotta know gotta which one this
is a very controversial
thing okay don't be a sheep and say
seven i'm joking
easy let the man talk actually my
favorite one
i i think this is probably kind of
controversial online
yeah titus titus can be a little
annoying at times but
i love that world i learned myself so
much yeah
just love the world the combat system i
really like in 10
i liked the spear grid but yeah the
franchise as a whole
i mean i play every single file so you
got the franchise all right last fanboy
final fight
final fantasy 7 versus six which one oh
no he don't want to answer that
they're just asking for some heat
you gotta choose between your two kids
sometimes which one if i if i use i'm
gonna go seven
oh my god let's go six brendan lee we're
kefka at now
let's go you know yeah
he started his career in super nintendo
oh my god
i don't know if i could take this word
you can't take his word now
i can't so i'll be a messy movie you
realize you realize the final fantasy
series
was on
oh man two more this is so hard
especially because i play like every
genre
um let's go
and let's go back into the past again a
game that just means the world to me on
a personal level
i'm gonna go super mario world for the
super nintendo
yeah super mario i thought you're about
to say zelda
i do love me some zelda but super mario
world was probably like the first game
on the super nintendo that i really
played played
like as a kid that just i mean it's my
favorite mario game ever
part of that's probably biased because
it was my first mario game but
yeah i'm gonna go super mario world in
there and then
turn around um
let's go
let's go god of war got to work 2018.
yeah let's go just asking you a question
because me and king you know
we we we have this little back and forth
thing what's your favorite zelda game oh
lord
shut up favorite zelda you know
if he say skyward sword
turn this off in a moment yeah if he's
saying that would be crazy
favorite favorite zelda is probably
going to be a link to the
past you didn't even get none of that
good got good okay all that matters is
it's not
the tyrannosaurus rex you and i are both
in the bushes yeah
and last the tough question i think i
the answer to this is um favorite
console of all time
oh wow that's tough
if i'm gonna say best memories like just
like the best
memories from his xbox 360. wow
yeah it was that multiplayer man yeah
that resonates with a lot of people it
really is because like
xbox 360 is like my first diving into
online play
like really in a real way like you know
just so many amazing online games there
was still so many amazing third-party
games let's shout out to dead space
bioshock
i mean i mean dude just just so many
you know it it probably was the the
console that
you know it was probably the one i have
the best memories on
salute to benji okay fantastic gaming
list
history all type of stuff man we're
going more
i know tom is limited so um last week's
poll results are in
and the people have spoken to the
question with the mostly negative
reception
by halo infinite by gamers who do you
feel is most to blame
for its poor showing at the xbox i'm
curious on the results
the unbelievable winner of our
four way ilp first ever
first ever last choice victory
was craig the grunt
stop bullying and leave my man alone
coming in at second place at 27
was three four three they've had enough
chances
covered in third place at 18 was xbox
one crosston being forced to develop for
the lord platform
a last place and only 13 percent of the
vote was bad messaging and way
over-hyped halo infinite group shout out
to all the law to participate you know
where you made the mistake don't you
putting craig in there you put you put
an individual that spawned his own
existence last week
craig was bigger than the pole well he's
clearly
you know so have any thoughts on this
listen i i think it was
it was honestly it was all three four
three like i again i
shout to the heavens that i just do not
agree with the art style everything else
feels like it's halo and everything and
we'll talk about
you know where the where the franchise
is going in a minute
um but it's funny because i was
listening to a podcast this past week it
was either the game informer show or the
beastcast
and one of the panelists was talking
about how they they asked their kid
who's about nine or ten years old
to look at the halo infinite demo right
and just tell them
what they thought about it they have no
sort of affiliation to halo never played
it
just give me an honest answer what you
thought about it after seeing it
and you know kids kids honesty sometimes
is is scathing
yes so the kid watched and he said
it looks like skylanders with guns
and i was like it's it's funny because
me listening to it
i'm by myself and i'm saying to myself
yeah that's right they do look like
skyrim oh my god
so that to me to me it was a choice that
they made that i don't agree with i
don't think i'll ever agree with
um but it is what it is
now real quickly before we get into the
topics lord benji please let me know i
know you're unlimited time let me know
how much time you got
i just don't want to get anyone in
trouble how are we doing on time sir
we're good
i can go until about i mean whatever we
got probably at least another
hour in me if you need it oh my man okay
cool
let's do it man i gotta respect this all
right so you you're gonna hear the name
jim dance movement relax relax
hold on let me get the whole king like
took the cape off it was like this
just just wait a second just if i could
send you something i
would just wait a second just wait a
second man
look so let's get into it let's get into
these topics so first one up obviously
you know the success of grounding you
know it definitely kind of came out of
you know nowhere for us uh
for a lot of us you know what i'm saying
i want to actually salute benji at an
amazing let me get an amazing tweet that
uh
literally said you said uh grounded was
developed by 13 people in two years
it hit one million players in 48 hours
and it's still currently the number one
selling game on steam
i thought you were about to say some
like ufc stuff and still
it's still
yeah man so it's kind of taken the
gaming world by storm in a way
and um definitely want to get into that
so obviously we've seen not only the
sales numbers we've seen the streaming
numbers we've seen twitch concurrent
views
i mean all this data that has come out
in reference to this
you know game so my get question to the
realm is a star wars love benji is like
how surprised are you and then the other
question which i kind of want to
um phrase is that as the hardcore gaming
community
you know saying like how how does does
this prove that we're
like the minority here as far as like
projections and what games are going to
sell stuff so
take it away lord veggie what's your
thoughts on this whole grounded thing
yeah so first of all in regards to its
clear success i will say it definitely
caught me off guard to this level
i i'm not surprised that it found a hook
that it found an audience you know
survival games in general is a huge
genre
really really big um but i was not
expecting
this kind of performance that i don't
think obsidian or microsoft word either
especially
the thing that's caught me the most off
guard about all of you know there's tons
of different data points to look at
the one that's caught me the most
surprised is how consistently it's been
the number one yellow
selling game on steam i mean it's been
like every single day since
i'm refreshing it right now and it is
still number one
yeah destroyed by humans just came out
that's number two
massachusetts three but yeah and four
four guys that just came out is uh
four and five but grounded as of right
now as we speak
it is still number one yeah that is
shocking to me it's not shocking it hit
number one
let's say for like 10 minutes but for
days
i mean that's crazy i think what it is
who did that for you
i knew that was covered i knew that was
good
oh you bug snacks dudes like right now
like you know when
you know when something happens and
y'all don't want to see because i know
when something really hit the streets
benji this is okay
[Music]
i laughed and i was terrified same thing
for me
when i saw that spider that spider
caught me off guard what's funny is i
was talking about the spider right
before it happened
and i went around a quarter and like i
felt like my heart leaving my body oh my
god
so he kept running and then it was mad
spiders it wasn't just one
i was like oh they got crazy bosses all
over the place i got to go right gotta
go left
it got to the point where there's so
many spiders i had to jump in a soda can
yo i knew it was lit
when my son came to me crying
what all right listen so you know how
you got to pre-pre-load it right yeah
he pre-loaded it before the day he said
daddy
is the 28th and i can't play the game
i said what the hell are you talking
about what game you can't play
because that was a limited beta i went
upstairs to his room
i deleted it off his hard drive and
redownloaded it he came downstairs
i don't know probably like 20 30 minutes
later or whatever i was getting
something out of the refrigerator he
comes and gives me the biggest hug
my cousin sage i use him as the
definition of casual game
right and i walked in the other day and
he was playing grounded like
he he's the he he's the person that
brings these numbers up
he played see these for like three
months straight every day wow
like he he plays all these survival
games and i'm like how you like it he's
like it's got some issues but it's a
good game like
he told me it's extremely polished like
when it comes to these type of games
the polish that's on grounded yes is
is way above all the others
the funny thing is we we call them
casual gamers but like people who play
these type of games are hardcore
hardcore
hardcore facts so let's get let's get
benji on this
again sorry to write you as far as your
analysis was like the surprise of this
like what do you make of all it yeah
it's like i said
the thing that has been the most
shocking to me isn't just that it was a
quick spike and then gone
it's that it is still number one i mean
it doesn't take a whole lot to be honest
to top
the steam global bestsellers at launch
if you do it for
a day you know it doesn't take that much
but to consistently
for almost a week straight be number one
i mean that means it's resonating big
time that's a big audience it seems to
be doing well on game pass i'm sure
as well and it's it's huge
hugely successful like i put out in that
tweet 13 people made this game
i'm sure i'm sure they brought in a few
other people you know
contracting and stuff to help polish it
right there at the end but the vast
majority of the development was 13
people
in two years the budget is going to be
tiny tiny tiny budget
that game i can guarantee you right now
today is already profitable
wow
i'm going to check the most uh popular
and see where it is that's crazy
so okay so we got wow that that this is
like really stunning i mean
again just to see that and just in
reference to the second part of my
question uh lord benji in reference to
you know hardcore gamers you know what
i'm saying and a lot of them
you know i'm guilty
you know like so it's just like you know
when you look at the games i guess my
question is when you look at the games
that dominate
the market from a sales standpoint right
um does it surprise you that sometimes
it's not
you know necessarily always the
you know narrative single player story
driven type game and a lot of times it
ends up being sometimes the fortnites
and the
you know in this case the ground you
know what's your feeling on that
yeah it you know i this actually kind of
ties into a tweet i just sent out the
other day where i was like
i was saying one of my biggest takeaways
the last few years in the gaming
industry
is there's room for everything you have
free to play you have subscription you
have 60
you have single player you have
multiplayer it's important to remember
there are
hundreds of millions of gamers out there
so
you can have both you can have ghost of
tsushima come out and do amazing at 2.4
million units in three days and then you
can have something like grounded which
is
literally as far of an opposite of ghost
of sushi but as you can get
also be a giant success so it's
important to remember
you know this is something i have to
remind myself every single day when i'm
doing research is to try to set aside my
personal biases when i look at the data
you know just when i look at the data
because
um i'll be honest i haven't even played
grounded yet i'm more of a single player
i'm right
playing goes to tsushima like crazy but
if i'm if i'm going to look at the data
correctly
i have to ignore that i have to ignore
what i like absolutely and look at
everything absolutely
powerful statement and uh i i just if if
you want to
get the best analysis that's what you
have to do and yeah it's important to
remember like so many of us like kind of
i mentioned at the beginning of the
podcast we get locked into our
own bubble and we forget about other
things so
i think that was i think grounded was a
prime example where you saw a lot of
people memeing and making fun of it
and then they forget they forget about
that giant audience that loves minecraft
that loves
sea of thieves that loves these games
and they're turning out they're turning
out i gotta give you the on to something
emoji you are on to something well i
mean a lot of those people got that egg
on their face
shout out to y'all guys
you know what's crazy though like the
fact that these games that
we don't think is gonna like really
surprise people end up always so
like surprising people i know i'm gonna
say this and kings go over there and
glow
see these yeah
uh first let's get a mariano bumper with
the fight on super chat some got some
shows ago you guys mentioned xbox top
game sales were mostly third party
now look at steam's top sales on
microsoft studios yeah uh
four out of the top ten selling games
sea of thieves
microsoft flight simulator grounded and
master chief collection and it's been
like that for like a week
for a while yeah they're having
tremendous success on stage yeah who did
that
shout out to this shout out to the steam
people that won't leave steam for no
reason so they they'd rather buy the
game at full price
then go and get game fast
that's definitely allowed you to play
your games wherever you may choose
you know what's funny it like like phil
literally manipulated
like he was like look we're gonna give
you the option but it's gonna be an
illusion
we know you ain't doing that solve your
thoughts on this thing
yeah oh well okay to start off with the
quality of the game
yeah i really i didn't really much have
doubt in the quality of the game um
since obsidian became part of xbox
studios i have to say to me
they low-key became the goat studio for
them like they
say a lot of people in the back say
obsidian obsidian knows how to make a
game they know how to make a quality
game they know how to
finish the game and put it out in in a
relatively timely fashion
um they took what was uh technically
like a broken mess
in fallout new vegas but the game was
fantastic
um these guys to me have taken over that
top spot
in xbox studios and so i didn't really
doubt the quality it was just a matter
of if
if there was a place for it in the
market um and again
you have to remove yourself from those
biases when you talk about this stuff
because here on the show we're going to
talk about what we like right
and i when i answer a question i always
like to see the other side of the
argument as well because
oftentimes that side of the argument is
the one that matters on a large scale
and not what i care about right
now what i selfishly care about um it's
just the fact that
so many people play these games and if
this type of game a survival game is
done well
where the the minutiae of the survival
and and
and the and the sort of collection of of
resources and stuff like that if that
part is fun you're gonna have people
that gravitate to this sort of game and
you're gonna have people to gravitate to
watching this sort of game right
it doesn't surprise me it doesn't
surprise me um
what makes me laugh though is like you
see you know you look at twitter and the
people the naysayers are laughing at it
oh my god it's hilarious
you know this is what this is
microsoft's bag this is their thing
you know yeah i get it at the same time
they're laughing all the way to the bank
and i can't
you know it's not for me i will probably
never play grounded
i will probably never play fortnite
right i
can't i can you know
like again completely like i said la
benji said it right
as far as being in our bob own bubble
taking our own personal biases out of it
and looking at the data looking at the
trends let me let me jump in real quick
cause
this is a fun topic and um i gotta say
you know shout out to
to the lords of obsidian and what's
funny is they were my favorite
acquisition
and i doubted them i gotta bend the knee
yo i admit
i was i was wrong i was like who is this
for why are they making this you wasting
voices
i actually like i think i think i
downvoted the whole conference because
i saw that i was so you can go back here
we have a reaction
disgusted grounded on top of that
we got let's be real and shout out to
stigma who's made a good point
you know you got social media twitter
right gaming twitter and they're like
who wants this you see the memes of max
with the finger
the game is being kind of low-key clown
right right
oh yeah yeah i'm just like oh why are
they doing this this that other
but i gotta say it's like like when you
say you know this is a generation
this is a different demographic these
kids play these type of games and
i think the big thing was the twitch
streaming it's a great
streaming game the engine is clean
it's polished you know what i'm saying i
like the even the menu is very
outerworldy i definitely like the feel
but it also to me solidified obsidian
as the the midas touch like as far as
whatever they
touch goes to go whatever whatever
really cat daddy's joining
some people i know but some people don't
exactly my son is not playing last of us
that's a fact it's a different thing so
the thing what i want to say about
obsidian with the minus touch is that
you know you got you know for me i
looked at them like boom they got out of
worlds right that's the fallout game in
space i didn't know i needed right you
got that
then we came from the conference we let
everybody put it on switch remember that
yeah i don't even know how that happened
but we don't get it
then you know we got a vowel right that
seems to be
that vengeance right data is showing
that is a game that people
are really tuning into the metrics
excitement possibly
on skyrim right with the outer worlds
they can't they
they dethrone fall out they're like
we're coming for you next skyer
and it's like you know so you have that
so again i'm not paying grano and now
this could be another success shout out
to the developer who made the video
you know you could see he was emotional
it was really cool to see
you know what i'm saying his response to
grounded and people take it to it and
the last point i want to say
is that you know because of the the the
financial success like you said lord
benji and
microsoft they already made their
investment back already you know what
i'm saying with this 14-man team
you know like do you think you know this
strategy like you know as far as this
like i said for for getting in on the
steam all stuff do you really think
this could really help them long term
like this quote unquote game pass game
now
grounded being on steam absolutely
i think microsoft honestly i'm going to
be honest with
you some of the playstation fans might
not like it but uh
i think xbox strategy currently is
genius wow i think that we're
already seeing it pay off you know if
you look at steam i mean three
or yeah three is it three out of the top
ten right now or microsoft
top ten right four out of the top ten
here's the thing people are
kind of maybe don't realize this yet
microsoft is rapidly becoming
one of the biggest publishers on the
planet on pc
i mean i mean you're when you're talking
how many publishers have four out of the
top ten
that's unbelievable right there when you
look at game pass on pc when you look at
i think xcloud is going to be huge i
think it's going to do much much
better than stadia ever dreamt of doing
tying that into game pass
is genius so you know
microsoft's on a heck of a run to be
honest with you
people are going to kind of make fun of
stuff like grounded but i think it's
important to remember obsidian also has
a vowed
right it's not like one of these things
where it's like 200 people at obsidian
made grounded
they're not going to make anything else
we have a vow on the way as well
microsoft seems to be allowing their
teams to kind of do whatever they
want at least from all the reports from
the studios
um and this was something that obsidian
felt that they needed to do
they wanted to take a small passionate
team and make grounded and then here you
see a enormous success
um yeah obsidian's on their way to be
one of the premier studios at microsoft
unbelievable yeah shout out to those
guys man just really success story can
you want to wrap up before you move on
because i know we got
we got 320 people in here man definitely
hit that like button if you guys don't
know
it was just the fact that um sorry let
me get these super chats first you gotta
go get it okay
we got cat daddy with the five dollars
we chat we have over 300 people in here
give row company a try after the show
everyone yeah he's just saying that
because he's playing with nobody over
there so he went to 300
sony made ghost of sushi meal for a few
oled guys obsidian said
hold my beer and drop the grounded for
the ttl majority
who did that wow savage
then we have hold on we have the medic
with the five dollar super chat remember
the studios xbox picked up all had the
same two problems
time and money yeah all will surprise us
in the future now that they have both
and you know what's funny it's like i
was telling cognito a couple
uh like about a week ago i was doing
research for a video
that i was making yeah and after
researching all the studios that
microsoft bought only two
the majority of them make 80 plus
metacritic games yeah if the only people
that don't really do it is compulsion on
undead that's all yeah
moving on soft yeah we have bounty boom
with the two dollars
chad good afternoon everybody hit that
like button yeah guys we have over here
320 in there man there's lord benji in
here man show some love
hit that like button man and also
subscribe to his channel too benji sales
man hi
benji hyphen sales on youtube we'll
definitely have to put that in the car
we'll definitely put that in the comment
section we're all caught up as we got to
move on y'all
yes sir all right anyway like i was
saying um
i think this falls is uh a level of
competition with the
developments houses that are in
microsoft's uh stable
because when one development house looks
over you see one
outperforming or outpacing the next then
you're gonna have a level of competition
that raises all you know
uh sales so i really think uh ninja
theory is bringing it
uh within next outing because a lot of
people didn't feel like bleeding edge
was that way
right i thought art direction it was
great i think
a little bit more curation of the game
they should have put it in beta first
and left it in beta for a while and
curate there
but it can definitely turn around so i
it's going to be in game pass forever so
i don't know if they're going to
allocate any more funds but we do see
that those successful games that do make
it
those teams will get more uh
compensation and
allowed to have uh different moves later
on i do feel like the moment this game
came out was a success like
they already have a bigger budget
they're like look like you know
let's give them a look let's cut them a
little check
let them hire a couple people let's
let's let's do some updates on this game
because clearly it's it's it's it's i
think
it's not going to be the same level that
ghost was says sony but i think it's one
of those things that happened and
feels like yo that's working yeah people
feeling that grounded like you never
know you never know so
we caught up hey we got cat daddy with
the five dollar stupid jack
wait a minute i don't know if i still
have sleep in my eyes the lighting on
his camera
but so i'm looking like a brother right
now off camera he's
he's doing this at 4k 120 yeah
we gotta move on man we got a but we
gotta get a move on so look let's get
into
the next topic and uh soft man i mean
it's a lot of announcements on your
topic
it was obviously halo
and i do want to throw something in
there real quick for you to solve
it looks like this is i don't know if
this is fresh off the press but
it looks like the in the halo infinite
store uh one of the
things listed under is battle royale i
think that just showed up
yeah they translated it um
so let's break this up because when i
first came up with this question
uh it was before the multiplayer stuff
the free to play stuff came out
right so we'll do that second so the
first part of the question was something
that i specifically wanted to really ask
benji
benji what do you feel about the halo
franchise proper becoming a platform
right with this 10-year plan now for
halo infinite
um it looks like they're largely going
to do the same thing with with forza
right do you think the rest of the
pillar franchises follow suit
do you think this is something is a
positive thing for the franchises will
there be some pushback from the
community
what and what and if that is the case
what do you feel that microsoft does to
sort of
continue creating this sort of living
world apart from the multiplayer stuff
right yeah it's an it's an interesting
question
you know you like you said you clearly
see that it seems forza is
going to go the same way there's no
number on that game it's just forza
motorsport
halo infinite i you know we don't know
yet but if you notice fable is just
called fable
if the plan is to just keep expanding
the fable universe over time
you know we don't really know yet but it
definitely seems clear that microsoft's
plan is yes let's get a game out there
let's support it really long term
maybe you see a sequel eventually but
for a really long time we're going to do
this i think it makes sense with game
pass specifically
because you're you're having a huge
amount of people that are accessing your
game
you know they're already in you're
getting huge player numbers right off
the bat
earlier than you would normally if
you're just selling a game for 60 bucks
so on one hand i i totally think it
makes sense the only thing that slightly
worries me
is you might get yourself kind of boxed
in if halo infinite does not have good
reception
you have seen games change over time
stuff like rainbow six siege for example
but that was
really multiplayer focused and maybe
halo infinite can improve on multiplayer
if it's not well received but what about
those single players and things like
that and the engine itself and the way
the game looks
you know that is the one risk when you
go with this platform
strategy is at least with a quick sequel
let's say three years
if the game is poorly received you're
like hey we got another shot three years
later
maybe we could turn this ship around um
so so that is the one risk you run into
we are in an age though where you're
seeing this more and more often
rainbow six siege never got a sequel and
they haven't announced the sequel coming
they said it's just gonna be support on
nextgen if you notice destiny 2
yeah we'll see right now luke smith got
in front of that he said that yeah put
another number yeah yeah so this is a
direction a lot of the industry's moving
towards especially games with
multiplayer heavy you know
you're not seeing it as much on the
single player side but
um i get why they're doing it largely i
think it's a good business move i just
do
worry a little bit about you know maybe
some of the bigger things like
like you know the very mixed reception
to the way the game looks all right let
me double down on soft see what i was
going to talk to the second part
or you still have more when you're at
your point just to that do you think the
other franchises do the same do they
create like
they do they create a uh uh gears
and and it's just the gears world and
they just keep adding single-player
content to that do you think they would
do that for the rest of their pillar
franchises
i think the next gears will be that way
yes i think gear specifically for sure
is probably going to go that road
um i i don't think it's necessarily a
for sure thing with every franchise
you know um especially something
probably like a
vowed which i'm guessing is single
player only we don't know
maybe that has a large multiplayer
component but it my guess my hunch from
obsidian's previous stuff like the outer
world
you know fallout new vegas and things
like that i'm guessing that's
pretty much single player so you
probably will see as just direct sequel
to that if it's received well
so i think it's kind of going to be a
case by case scenario but i'd say games
that have like big multiplayer
components like gears yeah i think gears
will just be a platform
moving forward and halo and you know
that type of stuff for sure
for horizon i bet it's a horizon it's
just going to be a platform yeah i got
that feeling
just they can just introduce new areas
you know the theme of forza horizon is
each one's like a new
country a new place to explore they can
just drop a whole new
world right into forza horizon so yeah
all right so i'm going to get i want to
get uh the other parts of the halo
question if you're finished with
the platform well yeah let me get these
uh let me get these for you
here we have r b three with the five
dollar super chat addict i need
answers your energy went from excited
child to an angry teen
as soon as the ponies got in your air
about halo what's real anymore
box he's out of control okay we'll
answer that for you
uh-huh it was the reveal okay
fair enough what else did you said the
supercharger yeah we have big cloud
gaming with the ten dollar super chat
hello salute to the iron lords much love
family what up benji good to see you on
here
awesome hello bad big clown you already
know you can get you in the room too
we're all caught up yep we're kind of
cool so let me ask this cause we gotta
leave it directly to benji since
getting close to time um yeah so
basically we
so we got the platform thing all right
then 343 they
they actually jumped at a huge
announcement right multiplayer
free to play and on top of that 120
frames per
second multiplayer so your thoughts
on this and is this the death nail for
xbox live gold and then another thing
benji
why didn't microsoft analysis on the
23rd
yeah okay so first i'm going to really
quick touch on why i think it wasn't
announced there
because i that's probably the quickest
ques our answer
um because we didn't see any multiplayer
yet and i suspect we're going to see it
probably here in august
so i think that announcement was going
to come pretty quickly afterwards
anyways and they were going to show the
multiplayer and just do it as one big
thing i don't think the
plan was for this to be announced i
agree i think i i don't think
we were supposed to know this yet right
so uh
i think that's the main reason i think
they wanted to be the big pop surprise
whenever they reveal twitter definitely
push that announcement out
yeah yeah so i i think that's the main
reason there if you gotta shut up craig
um and in regards to it going free to
play this is
gigantic i mean truly gigantic i don't
think you can actually undersell how big
it is
whenever you look at the biggest games
in the world league of legends fortnite
you know so many of this it is in that
free-to-play world with you know paying
obviously micro transactions
we'll have to wait and see how they do
the monetization that's always a worry
yeah anytime you go free to play it's a
little bit of a worry how you're going
to get that money back because they're
going to want to make money off of it so
let's see how that
is but um you know i was already
projecting
halo infinite to set a new all-time
record for the xbox first party for
players at launch i i was already
expecting that before the free to play
announcement because you have
pc day one you have xbox one day one you
have
xbox series x you have game pass this
game is
is prime positioned for an enormous
player base
at launch so i was already expecting
that now with it being free to play
i mean it's going to completely
obliterate the current record for xbox
first party it's not even going to be
close
because i mean when destiny 2 went up on
steam let's just mention destiny too
whenever destiny yeah when destiny 2
went free to play on steam for the base
to start off
i mean that peaked at over 200 000
concurrent on just steam that was just
steam not counting any other platforms
halo could easily do two hundred
thousand plus on team
hundred thousand who knows um shout out
to xbox live going down that day
yeah i know i i i almost responded to
the halo tweet that announced that i was
like i hope your server crew is ready
i think that i think just the fact that
you know grounded is staying at the top
of those charts like i can't imagine
what halo's going to do
yeah it's going to be giant so it's uh
it's a
very interesting move i will say this
sure makes me think xbox live gold is
going away
we already had some we already had some
hints that already started feeling weird
when microsoft wouldn't let you buy a
year
yep old and all sorts of things and now
halo the premier xbox franchise is free
to play
wow i don't know yeah it speaks to me
the gold is indeed
going on the way out very cuz i mean in
all sense gold like contradicts
their statements like they want to be
more open they want to be more
accessible
and gold is literally a barrier to
perfect people to prevent people from
doing it yeah absolutely i think the
writings
are definitely on a wall just a matter
of announcement and i definitely i just
want to double down on what you said in
reference to the free to play part
because
you know one thing being a destiny fan
yes delilah destiny fan i seen the
slander
he saw him benji was preaching a good
word about them steam numbers so listen
up
so the whole thing is um you know the
thing that i think is really cool about
the free-to-play aspect because i think
the
mistake a lot of the multiplayer
component games make
is map packs or dlc and then you're
splitting
up the base right so now not everybody
has it they can't play this you can't
queue him with this lobby
now you've got that ease of entry to get
into multiplayer and
with xbox live gold possibly going away
you know that could be huge for them
that could be huge and i honestly think
that
even though they may not have liked it
to leak this early
i think it actually helped them to all i
agree the negative
visual fidelity reception that halo
infinite
received so what do you think about that
i couldn't agree more
i mean right after the xbox event let's
just call it like it is
the vast majority of online discussion
was pretty negative around infinite
it just it just was and uh now all of a
sudden i've seen like a complete flip
around to a ton of excitement about
being able to access this
free to play now keep in mind that
doesn't you know get rid of people's
complaints that doesn't mean like
oh three four three is just totally off
the hook for like they don't gotta pay
for that multiplayer so it's okay
right yeah it's just it did in a lot of
ways changed the narrative
around what's going on with that game so
you know maybe they didn't want it to
leak but i think it probably was a good
thing as crazy as that is to say
yeah um so yeah i agree i think it's
probably turned around a lot of the
discussion on that game enough king
attic oh you want to get your bars up
before you go to the next topic
i mean when it comes to the free-to-play
thing i mean
let's just be real here they can't
compete with
fortnite right they can't compete with
war zone
right they can't compete with whatever
other ones that's out there i mean
i know um what's that other game though
other one that's like destiny
mm-hmm uh warframe they can't compete
with war
frank destiny is a in a lot of ways free
to play
yeah so it's just like look like at the
end of the day like
i think that call of duty is going to
take
a similar approach not necessarily make
it free to play but it's just like
unless you're a huge like the call of
duty and it's like i said i don't even
know if they're exempt from it
you cannot compete in this market unless
you're free to play
because the the thing is you want you
want an open door you don't want a door
with a
with a bouncer at it right like you you
want to just be able to walk in like
you don't want to come up to the big
where that ticket i take it out
i mean especially when they don't xbox
microsoft the only platform where
you technically got to pay just to play
fortnite free to play so this is another
reason why
that barrier for gold has to go let me
get king and king man i know you
you i remember when i was being raped
over the coals and attic was like
they will never do it don't you touch my
halo you move away from my halo
don't you make my hair
um
anyway it doesn't matter your knees are
mine
is the fact that i told you people and
y'all keep on acting like i got some
tinfoil hat
on and i told you where it was going
how i was gonna get that when i saw free
to play i said ha ha
and i i text messaged somebody and i
said what i told you
and then and then when that happened all
i needed all i
all i said to myself lightly while i
prayed to the xbox guy
very quietly to myself i was like please
xbox gods right now
royale at the end of this you wanted
that battle royale
speculation but right now you are
looking good you're looking
good right now they want that war zone
smoke
and any time you can have a bunch of
little master chiefs running around
throwing grenades and using pistols
and you're going to get that
winner-winning chicken dinner oh that's
going to
that's that's going to be the juggernaut
to battle for tonight
attic one minute rebuttal and we got to
move on
look man it's like i said at the end of
the day well i admit that she was right
about this whole games as a service yes
you were right in the context that
they're going that direction but i'm
still not been proven wrong that it
could be a bad direction
that was that was my whole thing i don't
mind if they go with the games as a
service
i'm very happy you said that i just
don't want it attacking the
right the foundation let me talk it's
all right
you're right you're right you're right
go ahead your interrupts per second is a
high continue
sorry sorry man i'm gonna i'm gonna call
let me just let me just end real quick
saying because we've been talking about
bubbles real quick right
right my bubble i i've always said i
want it i want halo to be up at the
upper echelon again right
right and sometimes in your bubble you
don't realize how that needs to be
achieved
right right and one thing we've talked
about is okay
halo in it of itself on just on the xbox
platform it
hasn't been at that top echelon right so
how do you do that right you
you put it out in a way that the entire
world can experience it with no barrier
and i didn't even think about really the
free-to-play stuff i was like nah that's
not happening whatever
so i may not agree with how the game
looks or whatever i hope it plays
fantastically but
in every aspect of what they're doing
with halo they're shooting for it
they're shooting to make it put it up
here with everything else right it's
just a matter of whether the execution
is there and they get it done
but i have to say that with this
free-to-play thing they're
going for it and i can't be mad about it
i can't be mad at that i can't be mad at
them for that all right so let's let's
catch up on these super chats for mulan
we have adam with the five dollar super
chat would you all be okay if xbox did
one massive game
in the way the witcher 3 did with ex
with a long game and a few massive
expansions
over a three-year plan see but would you
guys consider that as
exact games with the service like i
don't consider that at games with the
i consider that making a powerful base
game and then building on to the game
afterwards but
with the intentions of making a no
another game
but i'm gonna tell you this i would if
if the witcher is the standard right if
you're
looking at it sort of like that i would
love for halo infinite the base to be
that
right and then expand on its story wise
with the quality and
length of witcher stuff yeah i mean this
is i mean there's one more
three that's what lord benji was like
when lord benji tried to like
push the narrative a little bit that
fable might be against the service
i almost just left the podcast
i'm saying this right now if they turn
favor into a games
120 frames per second did xbox and craig
just slap addict and his tcl
is real savage savage man i
i like my tc you don't have to get off
my back with that t-shirt all right
final topic six minutes time we gotta
move
on man last thing this is king's topic
um
ea man are they creeping what's going on
bro uh
all right well so it uh comes to find
out that um
yeah are you going to set it up or i
mean i could sell it
yeah so pretty much like you know
obviously we know um
wb is a an interest for a lot of people
right now we've heard the rumors with
microsoft
obviously we heard um other people are
have bidded and entered
into the sweepstakes so it looks like
there was i'm gonna say an earnings call
benji that um
ea was on and i believe the gentleman's
name would be
pete jorgensen and i can't pronounce his
name but um
yeah he he basically outright
said it without saying it that ea is
interested in big acquisitions
all the studios that kind of thing so
basically alluding to that interest
right so
i know king kind of you know what wanted
to talk about that we know microsoft was
in the betting you know
just let's get straight to you budget
you got many times limited um you know
what
your thought process on this you know
with
ea in the mix does microsoft still have
a shot here we know a bid is in
you know where do you see this thing
going what's your thoughts on it
yeah it's uh it's going to be very
interesting to see how this plays out
one thing i can say is that
behind the scenes um companies are
looking at buying each other
all the time right all the time bethesda
at one point has been up for sale
um this kind of thing happens all the
time in terms of
people are are looking at possibly ways
to acquire each other it's very very
common that said
this one has a lot more smoke than the
other ones specifically because
a we've had very reliable rumors and
reports for a while but now like you
said ea
essentially outright confirmed wb games
is up for sale without saying the name
i said we're looking for big
acquisitions we're as interested as ever
ea was one of the companies that was
reportedly trying to buy wb along with
activision and microsoft
microsoft definitely still has a shot at
this for sure i think it's going to be a
question
of what is the licensing agreement
with those ips yeah yeah that's going to
very much affect the price that you know
they're going to be able to get for wb
if it's just the studios
it's going to be hard to get a super
high price tag because we do have some
amazing studios here we have rocksteady
we have another realm you know we do
have some very good studios but what
makes them valuable really is the ip
that they work on
um so i would say that factors in is
there licensing agreements at all
is it strictly just the studios um
it's going to be interesting microsoft
has the capital they can outbid everyone
if they want
it's all about if they want if they
really feel it's worth the purchase
microsoft we know is not done making
acquisitions phil spencer himself is
outright confirmed this is along with
matt booty
um so i would say microsoft is for sure
still in the running if i had to make a
prediction though i think it's going to
go to ea or activision
and now here's the question let me
double up okay
because because of what what makes you
lean do you think it because
uh wb's asking price is too high or
maybe the legalese with the fact that
microsoft may want those batman's those
you know those specific ips lord of the
rings is tied to this stuff
there's a lot of legalese contractually
that has to be figured would it be one
of those situations do you think that
microsoft just say you know what this
might be too much you know they may be
asking too much and not giving us
exactly what we want
yeah i think it's mostly probably price
you know microsoft people will bring up
the minecraft purchase and say look at
how much microsoft paid for minecraft
why wouldn't they pay for wb the key
there
is microsoft acquired the minecraft ip
yeah you know what i mean so if you're
buying the rumor is
billions of dollars for wb games and
you're getting
no ip with it maybe mortal kombat but
almost nothing else
it's a gigantic price tag i mean it's
really
really big it doesn't make it impossible
that they do this but i have a feeling
someone like ea or activision will be
fine
with buying that for a cheaper price not
getting the licensing rights but still
being able to work on those ip by
working with wb i think microsoft would
want more
exclusive rights right yeah add someone
like ea and activision
they can buy for cheaper work out a
licensing deal on top of it and make
their games multi-platform
questioning there you go that's my
thought uh obviously the rumor price is
4.5 billion dollars or something around
that line so
no it was um three three billion well
whatever okay
so 3.5 or 3 billion like
that's a lot of like to me that feels
like that's licensing with it because
like
that's a lot of money you know like like
when it comes to
they bought playground for 400 million
like
like and that was a high tier studio
that that makes
highly critical games like if you look
at it from like just
the studios that that this company's
made i know they make a lot of suit they
have a lot of studios
they're the people that make the lego
games and like a bunch of studios make
those games
but besides that like i think batman
rocksteady would be the most expensive
studio
because at the end of the day like these
studios don't come with ips besides
maybe mortal kombat
and like how much could mortal kombat
really like cost like
i think quite a bit like when it comes
to when it comes to
movies when it comes to that's what i'm
saying like when it comes to microsoft
they don't initially if they make big
acquisitions like this is mainly for
multiple revenues and not just one
like they would make stuff like this
because if they did get their hands on
the mortal kombat thing
they would license that outlet let
people make movies like they would make
a different ads of revenue
to make that money back quicker it's
just like four point
when you're like the billions like three
billion that's that's more they spend on
minecraft
that's a lot it's a lot king i won't get
you get your bars off all right um
so when i was on breakfast with boom
this week on friday
uh luke said something that was very key
uh the sale is incorporating the
publishing arm
uh microsoft doesn't need a publishing
arm and
if wb is being sticklers to
trying i don't think anyone would need
the publishing arm to be honest with you
it will help ea that's why i think uh
sir benji lord benjamin uh sales uh
he's on to something because in that
avenue that helps ea more than it helps
microsoft
if it's a package deal now i believe
microsoft is trying to
strip away of some of the components
that they don't need from it
they just need the talent right the
licensees
will go up for bid after the fact this
is where at t
makes their money they don't make the
money off the initial sales of the
talent being sold
they make the this the money off of
um the licensees being licensed out
afterwards because after you purchase
the talent now you have to shift through
all the licenses
that they're comfortable with that
they've been doing that these studios
that showed you they can do a proven
commodity
that you will put in their hands because
they know that license so well
so i don't believe that the problem
necessarily is the acquisitions of
the um the developers i believe it's the
uh publishing arm that's holding
microsoft's uh
hand in that avenue and i think ea will
be
more adapt to purchasing them with the
publishing arm opposed to microsoft
benji
so so let me ask you a question real
quick king yes
do you think that it's possible
microsoft might
try to go because i think all micros
microsoft obviously
they're heavily investing in the game
pass and i think you know
if they buy that studio i think games
like like the legos those are going to
be multiplied obviously i don't think
those are ever going to change
i just think they'll be day and day in
game pass and i think that would be huge
in general
like do you think that they microsoft
might consider
buying it just for the studios and
that's all
yes without the without none of the
licensing
just for the studio yes because this the
studios show you they definitely have
talent
i believe um probably uh another rooms
is the only ones that will come with
uh the yeah i think they'll get the most
mortal kombat
right and if they get mortal kombat they
have someone to make killer instinct and
i think
i it when it comes to microsoft buying
it's like i said they have to have
multiple avenues they can use it for
you have you know you have a killer
instinct dev that they've always lacked
i think that's the reason we haven't
seen the killer in scene right because
we don't have the videos it was sold to
amazon
right so purchased by amazon i i say
this
and and and then you know i'm i'm done
with it
but i think the less of the two evils is
microsoft
right right we think the developers
would definitely want to go there
when it comes to these studios because i
believe ea destroys franchises
and and and destroys uh development
housing
and the reason why i say ea does this
because ea takes this view
when they're purchasing a development
house they look at upper management and
look at uh
middle management and they keep all of
upper management
some of middle management and gut lower
level workers
right and because they have their own
lower level workers that they feel that
they can just plug into place
that they're paying half the price
exactly so
we all know when we go into any
restaurant we go into any store
the people that greet us are lower
workers right
the people are making our food are the
lower workers you very rarely see
upper management you very really see a
manager you have to call for a manager
if something goes wrong
nine times out of ten the lower workers
are the ones that
are the heart and soul of your company
they are the actual
word of mouth right so they make up the
bulk of whatever games and stuff that
you're getting forward
when you got that out of a development
house
you lose the soul so a lot of games that
you
you see being made by ea after they
acquired a
company it's because they got gutted out
the soul of the company
so the game no longer reflects what it
used to be so
i feel that they are aware of this yes
it's totally terrible so i believe
microsoft keeps them intact and they
understand
that the heart and soul is the common
worker
so i believe that microsoft is a better
place yes i'm biased i say it
100 i will love everything to go inside
game pass and i would love for them to
make great games but
as a whole i would think that it's
better
you know let's go benji's thoughts on
that
um yeah no i actually think you're spot
on with pretty much everything you're
saying
um i would say if microsoft buys these
studios i don't even think they're going
to work out a licensing deal i think
they're all going to go on new ip
or microsoft owned ip i don't think that
microsoft has really any interest in
licensing batman or harry potter for
multi-platform
um the only way you would see microsoft
working out some kind of licensing deal
i think is if it was
permanent or very long term 10 plus
years they are the only ones that can
make batman games and it's exclusive to
them
otherwise i think you're going to see
rocksteady on new ip i think you're
going to see
all these students like i said either
new ip or an ip microsoft already owns
right um i don't think there'd be any
licensing deal they'd work out wb
whereas someone like ea or activision
would be more willing to do that on top
of it so i think
those buyers are a little more enticing
um
than microsoft is unless microsoft pays
big you know i think microsoft if they
really are going to do this they're
going to pay a lot of money bottom line
yeah
so okay i want to get solved because we
got we got to keep getting [ __ ]
moving okay to be honest with you benji
like i just want your personal opinion
all right
to me i feel like batman's big don't get
me wrong batman's huge but if they
picked up this studio i kind of would
like them to hit up marvel and make
another
superhero because i feel like batman
batman's kind of run its course it's
still huge don't get me wrong batman's
still going to sell regardless
but i think another hero like maybe a
black panther or something
re-initiate and bring bread bread into
the brand like
if you literally just take batman let's
say they can't get the brand and they
just use
they reuse batman it's like i feel like
you're going to have a lot of good
good positive energy but if you just
left batman with warner brothers and
talk to
to marvel and use another one like you
know
maybe even spawn i think spawn would do
good too and put that in there i think
that would have
a bigger
you know dizzy i was right with final
fantasy 7 and i'll be right here
so you know it is what it is get your
balls off
let's go first let's yeah let's get the
10 last super chat from slow mo black
slap
if ea buys w gaming it's going to be a
lot of unemployed people really soon
either immediately in layoffs or on the
studios they don't want
or not long after due to being ruined by
ea's way of doing
business so i think my answer sort of
speaks to that a little bit um obviously
yes i would love to
see microsoft take them in um but i do
agree that
you know for that amount of money you
would think you have
at least some limited sort of licensing
with some of their biggest ip but again
i don't know the details of that
whatever because at that point if you're
just buying the studios and you're
buying the talent
you have to think about forget about the
purchase price you have to think about
how you support these studios moving
forward
they're already supporting 15 other
studios right so
do you the the the talent on these teams
yes
would produce games i think that that
in a lot of ways are in genres they're
not strong in right right
so it would be i think would behoove
them to do that it's just a matter of
monetarily is
when they look at how a studio runs day
to day
are they willing to put that investment
into those teams
and not to mention so like do they even
have the people to manage all these
students
and that's the thing i mean we know
we've been talking about that they're
they're not done purchasing right
um and they're very good at letting the
studios that they do pick up
sort of do their own thing um and i
think these these
these sort of devs like the the nether
realms the uh the rock studies would
appreciate being in an environment like
that
so i would like to see it happen i don't
know that it happens now speaking to ea
i think ea in a lot of ways
and i'm not saying i'm not forgiving
them for what they've done right
but i think they've learned from their
mistakes in a lot of worlds
right in some ways right let's look at
this rumble
i got to see a game first i i know i
know when you
you saw jedi fall in order all right he
said he knows something hold on
uh-huh oh it's not like all as it says i
do know a lot of people that work at ea
and really love it
i just got to be honest there are a lot
of devs that really love working for ea
i'm not the biggest fan of to be honest
this generation i think ea has uh to be
honest
in terms of market performance i think
they've underperformed considering the
ip that they have but uh
but i do know a lot of the devs actually
think that ea is a pretty great place to
work
right they like that paycheck
i think they've learned from you know
the battlefield the the battlefront two
kind of fiasco they they put vin sample
in the position of power and let them do
what they need to do
right and we just saw that and we saw
the results of that with
fallen order right um you see them
you know taking a game that's been run
through the mud in anthem
and trying to bring that back and fix
that right so
you you they realize that there's
certain things that they
cannot just that the boardroom has to
stay
out of the design room and and let
because that's not what the fans want
right so you have to have a balance
between making money
right and giving the fans what they want
so you're not constantly
you know being talked about in the
gutter so i think
if they were to take on these these
studios in these ip
i think they would they would figure
that out right i don't think they would
go in and say
how do we monetize batman right right i
don't think that's a thing
so like i said i would prefer them to go
to microsoft or
any anybody but ea or activism i think
ea sort of gets it that they cannot mess
with i think ea would definitely be a
better buy than activision
that's what i was about to say
activision is a hundred percent
guarantee gonna mess it up activision's
worst case scenario to be honest
yeah yeah yeah it's all good
if if active vision buys it i'm willing
to say
that all those studios will be shut down
we gotta move on we got it
so anyway new iop poll will be going up
with the recent success of grounded and
microsoft ips now having great initial
success on steam
do you think this pressures sony to put
more first party
playstation exclusives on pc sooner than
later
the choices are a no sony still values
their console equals
no really extra man more than xbox
b yes sony values extra profit
only a matter of time or c i don't care
if they
put all my exclusives on pc master race
i'm throwing playstation in the bushes
shout out to all those who rock the vote
salute to
the video games independent analyst the
amazing
benji sales two-hour marathon rock with
us
gave us an extra 10 minutes out of love
when you know he's a busy man
where can the fine people find you what
do you have going on sir
i just want to say first thank you for
having me on the the podcast it's been a
blast
absolutely love it this might be my
favorite one i've ever been on if i'm
gonna be honest with you
thank you you guys are amazing the
community seems
funny and in tune with the joke i love
it
so you can find me really two places uh
on twitter i'm at
benji sales i do a lot of my time on
twitter talking about the video game
industry
you know specifically sales and business
and metrics but also just talk about
games in general as well
um the other place is going to be my
youtube channel which is just benji
sales on youtube
we're we're close to two thousand okay
there we're close
yo i gotta i gotta i gotta toot the home
for you if you gotta not subscribe to
benji sales right now again put the
youtube thank you addict
benji click that button let's get this
man to 2k
the birthday's coming up we gotta get
that exactly
get him the 2k this is what and you know
this guy's on twitter like
extremely informative we definitely
don't you know
try to send our people over to someone
that we wouldn't watch i watch every
time this man goes live
it's a very entertaining stream he
interacts with his chat
so definitely go over there and
subscribe super humble straight
informative
no bias just telling you tell him what
what he sees based on the trends and
analysis
dude keep doing the show thank you for
coming around you know we got to bring
you back
thank you thank you i love that you are
amazing right after we get the metrics
on
these sales definitely gotta bring you
back man thank you again
for all your time if you gotta head out
right now we understand we'll do our
outros
awesome yeah i'm gonna head out thanks
everyone thanks guys
thank you man very much love and of
course lord
attic the unofficial time keeper for
lord king
on where could have found people find
you
what you got going on with these hot
videos man you know what king you have a
fraud alert i'm gonna get a clock
got a couple updates so you know i
talked to uh
uh the lord so we've all agreed that you
know we're gonna all string grounded
eventually
i'm just giving you guys solve told me
you would be able to stop said battle
toads
okay i guess it's not ground it's gonna
be the battle toad all right battle i
don't know how i feel about that
i want to do grounded though i i'm down
for either i'm down for you okay sorry
about this
we would we would do that we can't do it
hold up give me a second
time we will
we'll do battle toads because that
that's all the lords want to play and if
we get over a hundred members we'll do
ground
okay well we're gonna put it up to the
right hold the header grounded
is the success ground that is first
games with friends anyway this is we got
to get him out of silver single player
yeah
we definitely gonna have to call you out
on the how did i finish the game you
were supposed
to finish that man my man came to the
rescue
put the bushes in for solve y'all we
gotta get him to play some multi-player
games
i will dive head first in those bushes
every day
say something which one you all want to
do
so you know obviously i'm doing a lot
more content on my actual youtube
channel
definitely go you know a gaming ad you
can go over there check that out
i'm on twitter a lot here lately i'm
doing a lot of dumb stuff over there so
you can definitely subscribe
to follow me on twitter at lordaddictiop
and you can i'm going really good i'm
going on
i'm going to go on amazon right now and
buy a clock so
no there's got to be something that says
time to get yeah oh my god
hold on hold on lord oh that's george we
got it
shout out to lord jameson that's the
homie right there always miss you guys
live
just wanted to pop in and say keep up
the great work let's get the likes over
200. no doubt man salute merc plays
on twitch brother i see you what's going
on get hit us off
yeah we have gamers play with the two
dollar superchat just making my presence
known hashtag game on players yeah
actually we do have one super chat we
missed from last week so let me get that
in right now
shout out to the wise old gamer with the
five dollar super chat
all i want to know is if my uncle can
play spiderman miles morales on his tcl
to his cataracts
where can the fine people find your
non-multi-player game self
yes sir yo um first of all i want to say
shout out to benji man benji this is
awesome i'm gonna tell you this for the
longest time
in the gaming space there were two names
you think of when you think about
analysts right you think about michael
pachter and you think about matt
biscatella facts
um benji sales is with those guys that's
in that breath he's in there he's
he is in that bracket he's in that
category uh
young dude works really hard to just put
it get that information out there just
does it for himself yeah whatever
whatever connections he's created
throughout his years
um it's that's not an easy thing to do
when you don't have an organization
behind
and let me just interrupt real quick you
know for the fam
yo stop attacking son on twitter because
i see it in a couple times you know what
i'm saying
if the numbers that he reports ain't to
your favor or whatever
don't go after the man person because i
saw at one point i was meaning to talk
to when he was live at one point he was
thinking about getting off twitter and i
was like no like you're so informative
brother like
people really respect what you got to
say so show them some love
and if you don't like the news and just
don't like it or retweet it but don't be
common attacking the man
profile it was because numbers didn't go
your way the stats
flow your way that week like we got to
stop that but anyway sorry continue so
i'm trying to get that off yeah that's
the
reason
just so toxic man then we have jw's a
show with the five dollar super chat yo
king
i didn't know santa was on the panel
today tell him i want a series x
they're gonna let you live
i'm being shamed into playing grounded
so i may have to do that
yes yes get king get solved to play
multi-player okay
let's look look i'm sorry soft
i have to wear a trucker out overall
it's got no sympathy for you
okay we gotta get that done we gotta get
expedited ship it on your truck i don't
know
i don't know what it's still not here
tonight we got
first off i don't live in the hood
excuse me anyway
lord king on his best behavior for a
whole hour
then yeah
um it was a great show uh i love
exactly uh i i don't know why i always
call him
sir benjamin's yeah yeah because it
feels more gorgeous
it was very more lordly yeah you know
because your dog is your dog
that is true and it was like a freudian
slip yeah
but you know um i i appreciate
what he brings to that space because
each one of them
are completely different in how they
attack a situation
and he is like of our generation and
of your you guys generation but he
attacks it without the fanboy part yeah
and it is refreshing to see like he said
he has to separate himself
from the the his what he wants
to read the numbers for what they are
sometimes you might not want to hear it
and sometimes it's a heartfelt swallow
but um this week i have some uh some
uh statue racks coming in and finishing
up the back room today so at the end
today
that's why you didn't see uh anything
new this week because i'm
also ordering some major cases uh so the
king
heavily invested in major cases he's
trying to get me
um but uh soon you're gonna see the
whole display everything change
everything is gonna be
uh completely different but please go to
loadsofgaming.net and make sure that
to see exactly what everybody's doing it
seems like they're putting up articles
by the minute yeah because my phone is
on alerts for them so
sometimes i just jump in and i read an
article which is really crazy
but if you didn't see the last word
please go and watch the last word
with lol
get up and he's fed up and he takes the
argument and he
reverses it and he puts it on them and
they can't wiggle
free from it and he leaves it on their
back just like that and it's absolutely
funny i'm thinking i'm gonna watch it
again right now
y'all think i'm doing it like hyperbole
i
funny but also catch me on fridays at 9
00 p.m on guelph castle
x the best statue show in the universe
no you don't know you don't got for
tater response oh god
here we go shout out to 14 to find great
show guys please tell kong if you're
going to change the main perk on a
weapon
you should just make a new weapon
hashtag
in the past damn it we ain't going down
this time
time we can't
let king know tcl gang and they call
that full though
he put his ten dollars on that he put
ten dollars on that tcl king
he definitely could have put that 10 on
her old leg
yo tco gang repping be proud for a
little bit but we're gonna come get you
the next gen though
what happens when the next gen start
your tv don't work
you already know okay got your balls off
you're good i'm done man
again salute to the chat man 300 y'all
still in here we're on the damn outro
man this is so much love
salute the lord benji sales man analysts
we'll bring them back
ahead of me yeah it's kind of funny
eleven o'clock
kid come on
this this is all i have to say about
that
i'm done this man with his magic
talk so i can see the bad what's up
what's up man
i don't see that nonsense that man won't
go back to sleep y'all
look salute to the chat you already know
what time it is hopefully we have about
we have actually a fun
uh weekend planned next weekend i don't
want to spoil it too much
but it'll be one of our you know a cool
thing we got going on with the lords and
hopefully
another entity so stay tuned for next
week everybody enjoy your sunday we're
going to leave you
with this little promo from king and
we'll catch y'all 11 a.m but we should
go back to 1 p.m
uh so that attic could get some sleep
anyway enjoy
your sunday we out here peace hi
i'm lord king david of iron lords
podcast and
we're bringing to you an exciting new
giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able
to be part of that giveaway there's
two ways to get your name
thrown in the hat for the raffle
one become a member of the realm
that's hit that join button hit it hit
that joy
button you hit that join button down at
the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in
our community and this community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
as to who did that for you sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man